so
so
round one of the london chess classic
got off to an exciting start as world
champion magnus crossing drew a sharp
game against frenchman maxim vashila
grav america's number one hikaru
nakamura had a golden opportunity to win
this game but in time pressure he blew
it and blew his chances to go for an
early tournament lead the leader of the
grand chester vesseling topolove faced
off against the youngster anish geary it
was an exciting game topsy-turvy but in
the end it was the young dutchman who
was able to checkmate his opponent and
take the lead here at the london chess
classic round two
coming up next
welcome everybody to the second round of
the london chess classic we have live
shots from the auditorium in london
england as the players should be
arriving soon for their second round
here in the third and final leg of the
grand chess tour
my name is grandmaster alejandro ramirez
i'm here with grand master yasser sarah
one always a pleasure to be with you
alejandro always good to be here it's
been a fun tournament it's been a fun
series of tournaments and i expect
another good round today absolutely
so yasser what do you think about the
game so far the ones we saw yesterday
and we will see today i thought it was a
pressure-packed round yesterday i saw a
lot of good moves
throughout and i was especially
impressed by the honest gary not only
just
keeping the game alive and hanging in
there but also the way he uncorked that
combination with queen d5 i mean that
was a real highlight definitely
beautiful well let's take a look at the
results from yesterday anish kiri was
the only winner yesterday as he defeated
with black vesselling topple of the
leader of the grand chess tour
with the white pieces in a complicated
berlin alexander gristick was lucky to
escape against hikaru nakamura maxine
vasherla graf was easily held to a draw
by magnus carlsen and his fashion cop
sicilian fabiano carana with the white
pieces was unable to really put any
pressure on levon neronian who held
comfortably at draw and nothing much
happened in the vicia 9 vs michael adams
game a game that also finished in a draw
today's pairings have as the highlight
anish geary with white against michael
adams the youngster trying to bolster
his initiative in the tournament levon
aronian will be playing against vishy
anand magnus carlson will be playing
against america's fabiano caruana and
american champion hikaru nakamura will
be trying to bounce back from what
should have been a win
against maxine vashir lagrave and
at the very bottom of the standings
vesseling topaliv will try to with the
white pieces recover and beat alexander
grishchuk
and we have maurice with more details of
the key match-ups today
well round one certainly was a very
exciting start to this tournament and
the games were topsy-turvy despite the
number of draws there were certainly a
lot of exciting games
none more exciting than the upset from
yesterday where anish giri well he's
2800 is not so much of an upset close to
2800 but still he defeated vasily
topolov this is what he had to say after
the game
i thought i defended reasonably well and
he kept on
playing in the most ambitious way
and at some point he went a bit too far
i think
it was actually bad luck it's one of
these cases in chess when both players
don't see it and then one finds it by
accident it's just pure luck
well certainly understating his skill
these two players are not going to count
on luck however world champion magnus
carlsen facing off against his nemesis
fabiano caruana carano has not been
impressed by magnets of late the two of
them trading punches and magnus's form
has been awful throughout the year he's
going to see whether or not he can
somehow get some momentum going against
one of his great rivals fabiano caruana
but it's this matchup all eyes on the
youngster in the competition the
dutchman aneesh geary who will play
against england's favorite mackel adams
he's a veteran he's been around a long
time a solid player drawing yesterday
he'll see if he can hold the youngster
back hold back those dams and try to get
it start going here at the round two of
the london chess classic
and of course joining us live from
london is our very own woman's
grandmaster jennifer shahady
yeah here we are in the auditorium where
it all goes down just minutes before
round two of the grand chess tour london
chess classic yesterday really showed
one of my favorite moves so far in the
grand chess store queen d5 by geary and
today we have a super big game between
carlson and caruana so
just really excited to get the action
started back to you guys in the studio
thank you jen thank you jen and i was
actually very surprised about what geary
said because gear is not the type of
player that you're like wow he's so
humble he's so nice now when he wins
he's just like yeah i destroyed my
opponent i obviously saw more than him
right but he considered himself lucky
yesterday what do you think about it do
you think it was because of the time
pressure you think because he was
actually lucky to find his queen d5
resource what do you think he was
referring to when he said a lucky break
yeah well often times it happens in
chess
that you're
defending
and you're responding to your opponent's
initiative as best you can you're trying
to
keep the position so to speak and your
opponent basically says you know like
i'm challenging you to uncork a
combination i'm going to force you now
to attack me
and then suddenly it boomerangs the
combination that you're forcing your
opponent to play ends up being a winning
one and that's what i think he meant
with this
lucky uh if if at any moment vessel and
thought oh boy i'm worse he would have
just taken the knight right of course
and made a draw you know
but he did
no we see uh magnus carlsen just walking
in and i agree completely with you it
seems like he was forcing geary into the
combination and i'm wondering uh when
giri saw this queen d5 move what was the
precise moment that given you queen d5
works exactly that's a good question
then i have no idea
well hopefully we get to ask giri at
some point during the tournament but of
course we're going to move on to
round two as we do have the players
arriving here at the playing hall we
should be starting
so magnus coming into the hall there he
looked kind of confident typical swagger
i would say of the world champion that
never changes even though he's playing
against somebody that's giving him a
little bit of trouble lately right
fabiano caruana took a game against
magnus carlsen in norway a very nice
berlin win which we were talking about
yesterday actually not only did carlos
in blunder but by the time he blundered
he was already considerably worse i
think exactly but he came back and
carlson won in st louis here in st louis
with
well maybe that game was actually a
little bit lucky was it absolutely crazy
time scramble
remember the final move
you know that knee jerk response just
before your flag falls
and that's the least and that was the
losing move that was it that was it yeah
it really was so magnus cross and we'll
try to play uh hope a cleaner game this
time against fabiano caruana now
even though magnus has a nice score
against fabiano i think it's nine five
eight to five according to eight of the
statistics yeah eight to five between
fabiano sorry magnus carlson and fabiano
caruana but it's the last two years
where uh karjuwana has actually been
competing i want to say on an even level
it's been back and forth definitely
karana has won a couple games i remember
someone's that carlson has won with
black that have been pretty nice he won
a nice scandinavian against uh fabiano
in the olympia a very unusual e45 takes
takes knight c3 and the queen returned
to d8 right and of course the one that
we just mentioned here at zinc field cup
so carlson has definitely won his share
of games but it hasn't been a domination
the way carlson is used to dominating a
lot of his opponents exactly
you see lavon ironian arriving here at
the playing hall he had a very solid
game yesterday and i expect him to try
to
push a little bit against anand today he
will be playing with the white pieces
against fishy remarkably
they have played a lot
and it was absolutely during the reign
of vichy a non-five-time world champion
and what really surprises me is how well
aronian has scored in their individual
meetings it's just been impressive you
could never think about those two
players without mentioning that tata
steel brilliancy that a non one is black
i mean it stands out i feel it doesn't
matter how many games aronian wins when
they say
everybody will always think of that tata
steel brilliancy yeah was considered to
be the best game of that year and for
many of the best game played so far
since uh in this decade yeah and it's
definitely been a brilliancy
but that being said erroneous scores
very well against anand yeah in under
normal circumstances he has a lot of
wins with the queen's gambit declined i
think many of their uh struggles have
featured actually the queen's gamma dude
about playing d4 and englishes yeah so
definitely more of an english player
slash d4 player then he has an e4 player
something he uses very very rarely and
anan usually sticks to his guns either
plays the qgd or some kind of semi-slav
no nimizu indian once in a while
never really see him play king's indians
nothing along those lines
so we expect that the players will come
very well prepared as they are rather
predictable compared to i would say
other players in the field such as
carlson or nakamura so the preparation
here might be a lot deeper yeah and i
noticed in the match a
match uh this showdown in saint louis
that hikaru against karuwana was kind of
avoiding theory throwing out b3 and g3
and things like this
uh do you think he's going to be more
serious today oh definitely no doubt
especially
yeah especially after yesterday's game i
think nakamura really really wants to
get on the scoreboard he feels like he
should have won a game and
well he's going to have to prove it
today all the players are now arriving
at the actual playing hall
taking their seat as we see quite a few
spectators despite the fact that
we don't
have the game the games will not start
for a few minutes it seems right
uh this is unusual for me by the way to
see the players at round two
sitting in the audience taking a ch a
chair
waiting for their introduction as
opposed to just coming on stage and
sitting at their boards
normally it might happen at the very
start of the tournament as we saw on
round one that's standard protocol
but as the tournament gets moving
you would think the players were just on
stage but i suppose
the british want to do it for dramatic
effect
some kind of british formality yeah
we're going to have to wait a few
minutes i guess before the round
actually starts
and while we're waiting we just want to
review a slightly offbeat time control
that is used in
the
chess tour
the players will begin the first time
control with
two hours
uh each player has two hours but must
make their first 40 moves there's no
incrementer bonus during the first part
of play then there's a second time
control
which is one hour per player for all of
the rest of their moves
uh with a 30 second increment so it's a
slightly offbeat but a classical time
control number lots right with the extra
twist of the 30 second increment
definitely a relatively confusing one
yeah as we know what happened to the
world champion himself
absolutely we're gonna have to see if
they can handle the time better because
i felt they didn't handle time very well
yesterday right hikaru nakamura got into
time trouble he destroyed his chances of
winning but also wrestling topalov a
player that as you had mentioned is
usually quite fast got himself into very
deep time travel and arguably cost him
the game i think if he had 15 minutes on
the clock by the time geary plays 94 he
can think for about five to ten minutes
and be well obviously knight takes f2 he
has this brilliant queen d5 resource i'm
gonna go ahead take the knight and yeah
secure the draw
one player in the tournament in the
field
uh i feel the fisher increment fischer
bonus has saved his career as alexander
grisham
he is notoriously poor at
using his clock and so this time control
is actually a very dangerous one very
dangerous for alexander without that 30
second bonus suddenly and it really
creeps up on you you sit there and you
say oh i got 10 minutes for eight moves
then suddenly you have two minutes for
six moves and then suddenly you have a
40 seconds for five and it's something
that cost him dearly i remember that in
the norway tournament his game against
magnus carlos and the opposite color
bishop with queens yes that's it and
it's a perfect example right he again if
he had a little bit more time he might
have been able to maneuver outside of
the complications
but right now here he had the problems
and he was unable to hold that position
yeah as we have the tournament director
malcolm fame with the introductions on
round two to everyone watching on the
internet uh the seventh london chess
classic is the strongest tournament ever
held in the history of british chess
this year
it's the uh part of the grand chess tour
and uh we'll be updating both here in
olympia and on the website uh the
standings of the grand chess tour as it
all progresses this is where they were
before the start of the tournament the
tour consists of three tournaments uh
one uh instead of anger in norway the
norway chess tournament the sink field
cup in st louis and it climaxes with the
london chess classic here in london the
total prize bunk
and fifty thousand
uh dollars
uh there's an extra one hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in price fund uh
for the three top finishers in the grand
tour
now the uh london chess classic is held
in support of the charity chess in
schools and communities a nationwide
chess charity that brings chess
to children all over the uk currently uh
teaching chess in over 300 schools uh
we're particularly proud of our
association with one particular part of
the country which i'll come to
in a moment uh but
i just want to emphasize to everyone in
the hall and everyone watching online
that you could support the work of
jesse's communities and contribute
towards the continuance of the london
chess classic by uh donating money to
the charity either in the foyer here at
olympia or online uh by the charities
donate button on the charity home page
uh and thank you very much for your
support in in advance of that uh you
could give it all in all sorts of ways
uh credit card paypal all the usual
things we even take those old uh those
old pieces of paper called checks uh if
any of you
still use them now
anyone who's been here before all the
regulars of london chess classic will
know that the emphasis is on the
children
but the charity is particularly proud
that its flagship project
is where the olympics were held in 2012.
uh the charity has a fantastic
cooperation with the local council there
teaching chess into over 26 schools and
in libraries uh we've created the first
adult chess club uh and uh the children
are all doing extremely well some of
them are playing uh in the events uh in
the other room here and to my right and
we're generating some real real junior
geniuses
as well as helping to improve the
outcome of hundreds of children there so
i thought uh because we have the london
chess conference going on at the moment
the third london chess conference which
is about chess and society you can see
information about that at
londonchessconference.com
uh one of our keynote speakers was
councillor ken clark from the london
borough viewer so because he happens to
be here i thought we'd break with the
tradition and uh have rather than a
child making the traditional first move
we'd have councillor clark so i'll be
inviting him up uh in a moment uh to uh
to make the ceremonial first move so
first of all let's get the players on
the stage so please give a very big
welcome to
four world champions attended every
classic
vishyana from india
don't get tired of it i like the sound
of it you should look at this wonderful
piece of documentary on our media and
the cleverest nation on earth
uh cnn liked it so much they're also
doing another documentary so they're
going to need to talk to level at some
point during the tournament please
welcome from armenia level neronian
thank you and very much in form after
the european uh team championships
to a player known for his fighting chess
has been at the top of the world
rankings for so many years from bulgaria
vessel in toppo
playing vessel in another man who always
entertains whether it's his moves or the
fact that he's got to make 20 moves in a
minute
alexander christopher
now there are very few players who ever
get the privilege
of a mention on the daily show
but
one of the rising stars of world chess
right at the top of the world rankings
who's recently
changed his allegiance to the us which
is where he originally came from we're
delighted to have him here again fabiano
playing fabiano
a man who made a tremendous impression
on the one show on britain's most
popular talk shows a couple of days ago
uh
beating the presenter in 12 glorious
moves i think you might have a little
bit more difficulty this afternoon
please a huge welcome for the world
champion magnus carlson
the
tournament leader
drastic games
drafted
would
then
his game yesterday it was a brilliant
combination role
i loved it in the commentary room please
welcome anish geary
i'm playing anish
of course a regular southern chess
classic
the british number one long time british
number one michael adams
and now i'd like to welcome to the stage
from new york council council ken clark
will make the ceremonial first move
for maggie's carlson okay i know he said
you haven't played since school but um
try and
try and go back try and roll back the
years
what would you like to play
and remember it has to stay now
okay how'd you like that magnus
it's all right
thanks very much again
and so i'll pass you over to the chief
officer
and we'll get planned away thank you
well
it is working
well we seems to have finished the
second round of introductions wow i was
about to say that was quite some
protocol there i
was really
hoping to rush it up come on let's get
the games on the road hit that gong and
let's get moving does that bring you
back to the old european events
no this is very british it happens uh in
the top tournaments uh that you
introduce the players in round one
and then the players kind of drift and
sit and go on stages they're on the
stage thereafter but that was really
quite an
extensive uh commentary well and we do
have e4
finland who doesn't even have to make
the movie yeah p2e4 on the board
and well i was kind of saying while the
introductions were going that i didn't
think he was going to play e4 i didn't
expect him to go into some kind of
spanish for berlin but it seems that it
is the way we're headed but he's
thinking on move three
that is going to be spanish yeah
so caron i have always felt has a very
good grasp of the berlin and it seems
like he's not going to be afraid to go
right into it with knight f6
and look at that
that's like grimace
but he knew that he had to know it was
coming yeah of course right i mean
they've played this before i think they
played it in shankir
a couple of times so i want to say twice
in shamkir but i'm not entirely sure but
he actually chooses the rookie one
variation instead of the d4 variation
which is not considered to be
the most threatening it's one of those
variations that gives white a slight
edge exactly
nothing much to work with right the
berlin ending may be dry but it has
imbalances this
variation in particular i think is
really a very stale one
and i'm a little bit surprised by
magnus's choice
and um well away they go right
there you have it we have seen some
people actually manage to win with this
variation i think the game that's
impressed me the most is the game
between maxine bashir lagroff was white
in beale where he beat anish giri the
current tournament leader
in a very beautiful endgame
fully utilizing those pair of bishops
that you get with knight d5 you may also
recall that uh hikaru nakamura and a
singfield cup as white tried to grind a
little bit against magnus carlson magnus
giving up his light squared bishop uh
but again just because of the uh balance
very very balanced pawn structure like
you say it's a it's a squeeze it's a
it's a pull right but uh correctly
played it really shouldn't
uh
uh give white uh too much shall we move
on to some of the other boards let's see
what we've got see what we got we do
have uh a queen's gamut declined um we
actually got the right goes in with a
bishop before rigozin variation bishop
d2
now that is a very
unusual yeah and uh quiet but petite
little move actually i i
chase base dvd came out recently on the
regozin by
grand master ramirez
and
grandmaster
yeah the man sitting seated next to me
and what did you recommend against
bishop d2 i gotta say that i don't
remember oh
you're the man i just completed your dvd
okay i don't quite understand the move
though it seems relatively passive i
mean in most names of indian setups that
you force bishop d2 you should already
be quite happy with your position right
bishop d2 and it seems kind of strange
like uh is
besides just simply breaking the pin
normally you would want to play a move
like bishop d2 because you're aiming to
get the two bishops without
compromising your pawn structure but
after a move like say like castles
a i mean this just doesn't
seem like a much of a bishop uh sitting
on here on the c3 square yeah
with 94.
yeah 94.
yeah specifically this position i'm
wondering if i can just take the free
pawn on c4
and try to hold on to it
right
just in this moment
capture this and you want to play with
b5 and
no it's a
it's a it's a mystery okay well we'll
see how
he split it very quiet actually with
bishop d2 and e3 castles e3 not offering
the pawn so then this bishop on d2
often times when white plays very
quietly in a queen's gambit declined you
can as black simply drop back with a
bishop and then you say
you've encased your own bishop behind
your pawn structure why didn't you
develop it out earlier when you had that
opportunity right also
in these lines for example just in this
position go back
uh e2 e3 let's just use this as an
example kind of a rubinstein new nimzo
indian
oftentimes of white
with the bishop encased on
uh c1
uh
you would aspire
for queen side expansion and the bishop
is a lot
better place or
you might say it's out of the way on the
on b2 as opposed to the game position
with the bishop on d2 so we're not
impressed by levon
um opening thus far though i'm sure he
has some kind of idea exactly so let's
continue our uh ooh now this on the
other hand
is much much more to our liking
this is a very classical nimzo indian
style musician but e5
has really fallen out of grace from what
i remember i mean
d5 has lost a lot of ground to castle as
the main move absolutely absolutely
there was a recent
u.s
chess league
the championship
the saint louis archbishops against the
manhattan applesauce the applesauce came
through
uh but i remember on the first board
between ilya
nishnak i'm sorry if i get his name
wrong and alex linderman
there was uh the f3 variation that gary
kasparov
made uh popular
and you're right uh
d5 is kind of a throwback to the old
days right it's very
indeed
anish went a3 takes takes
knight e4
this is like the
the grand variation of the nimza with
knight e4
uh
i'm thinking of um
the
the line where they go takes and queen
takes d5
that's actually before a3 before a3
right yes uh from the kasparov anand
world championship match
so
let's go back for a second takes takes
knight e4 queen c2 c5
well this is pugnacious isn't it i mean
it just basically
very challenging to white right white
captured
knight c6
move knight c6 has the idea of now
playing queen a5 check in order to meet
the move b4 with knight takes b4
do however recall a game where um
vessel and topolof sacrificed an
exchange it was a really remarkable idea
uh i'll just put uh some moves on the
board just to give you an example
of what
vessel and
played remember there was a
line where he ended up sacrificing this
and he just said
look
i've got the two b's
i'm ready to play knight f3 castles and
bishop b2 and
you really challenge uh maybe not in
this particular position but there's
certainly a lot of compensation even in
that position it seems exactly very
challenging idea and oops sorry yeah
let's see what a let me get up to date
with the play i basically played knight
f3
do you assume the idea is to meet queen
a5 check with
knight d2
absolutely absolutely now just uh
for argument's sake when you get a
position like this your first instinct
is to say well
physician looks very balanced but really
what it's all about is white just
keeping these two bishops and nursing
them for as long as he possibly can
trying to take the game slowly slowly to
into an ending and this is almost a kind
of a dream position let me just put
white's dream position on the board
so you can get an idea that
this is by no means just as a disclaimer
history and position and my dream
facilities
are kind of different different things
from yourselves absolutely but these two
bishops is basically what white wants
he's got this great bishop on c3 and
bishop on c4 and black's going to have a
very very difficult time right building
this no i'm not sure that this would be
a dream position for me but definitely
it would be a nightmare for black no
matter who you are because you have to
defend a very uncomfortable situation
for a very long time some echoes between
uh the other board i just wanted to go
back because uh surprising for me
was the move c5
it does look very
in tune with the structure though to
play this liberating move c5
yes but at the same time now after a3
bishop takes c3 bishop takes c3 white's
strategy of winning the two bishops uh
has a greater potential of paying
dividends than in the previous position
because this bishop on c3 can suddenly
uh be unlocked so to speak so do you
think this bishop will survive for long
or do you think that vishy will no i
think this
fishy will hunt that sucker down and
take it yeah play in 94 and get which he
already did by the way yes certainly and
he and iranian quickly played queen c2
okay queen c2 so that position has the
potential with this central pawn
intention of becoming quite lively i was
afraid that it might really put us to
sleep a snoozefest but this game
still uh the opening is going to be very
challenging for both players since we
were wrong he decided to take uh cover
with a check on d2 with the bishop and
it seems like maurice has more insight
than us on this particular opening yes i
just did a search on this position and
it shows that actually bishop d2 is
pretty much the right move here because
knight d2 has a fatal flaw knight d2
allows this move knight to d4 and this
knight suddenly the queen is
bereft of squares queen to d3 is met by
the very sharp e5 and oh this is not a
position you want to play without deep
preparation bishop coming to the f5
square and suddenly a lot of pressure on
the board of really sharp position the
other possibility after 94's queen d1
but bishop to d7 with the idea of bishop
to a4 would be quite dangerous so this
is why bishop d7 is pretty much the real
only move
you could play this line it looks like
people have played it before but it the
research is seems like white has left
that line completely behind and plays
now only bishop to d2
thank you maurice that's a nice update
on the opening yeah knight d4 and e5
that was uh that's yeah that's kind of
scary it's one of those things that you
go to the game and you're like oh i
guess i'll play knight d2 i don't really
know what i'm doing right and then bam
knight d4 e5
should i have gotten out of bed this
morning
that's rough
and check this game out hikaru nakamura
mvl ikaru has a remarkably good score
against mbl he has won three games
not never lost and lots of draws i'm
assuming between them a few draws and i
do remember that actually actually maxim
escaped with a lucky draw
i want to say it was dissing inkfield
but i might be wrong it was
i believe it was a kind of night of
position
yeah something is uh coming back i can't
it's on the fingertips right i wanted to
say that as we know mvl is probably
along with peter swiddler uh one of the
leading leading experts on the grunfeld
along with cariwanna as uh grunfeld's a
very very popular
extremely popular defense in the world's
top
10 players i want to say so
uh a headache for white players who want
to play 1d4 don't want to face the main
line grunfeld to try to do something a
little bit offbeat
there we go
definitely not very ambitious
no it's not there's more than one way to
meet this okay let's see which one
maxine decided to bishop g7 by the way
i remember uh playing tony miles
and for example what tony did was he
used the queen side fianchetto against
everything right e4 d4 he would play b7
b6
so we sat down to play our game and i
played one g2 g3
and violating all the rules and
protocols of proper chess etiquette
tony leaned across the board and rather
loud voice he said i love these moral
victories
stopping him from each other so when
hikaru plays a move like e2 e3 you know
mvl can say very good excellent you know
yeah
my groomfeld survives another day bishop
g7 c4 you can always go d5 here well
i find it a
funny combination of the two moves if
you're going to play e3 you think white
is going for some kind of a tame
card variation d3 b3 yeah exactly so you
know
i'll say not c4 okay
all right
by the way this would be a very uh
simple transposition to a rather
known grunfeld line
i i know a friend of mine from the
northwest uh james harley-mccormick he
liked to play this move b2b4 in this
particular setup because he figured the
grunfeld players have only one ambition
which was to unleash their bishop
uh by playing the move c5 so the whole
idea of round four was to cut out
that fun if you will bishop e2 and c5
was played directly definitely already a
positional thread
if white castles then c takes d4 is
actually already uncomfortable for white
as knight takes d4 is extremely
unambitious this kind of hedgehog
positions are just nothing
or even even d5 will equalize and if you
take on d4 actually after d5 white might
already be worse
it's kind of uh what do you call it a
tarash reverse that is reversed
yeah it has no advantage for why the
extra tempo is not meaningful at all as
a karo khan player it warms my heart
yeah you say that black is more than
okay yes all right so that hence after
c5 well
that was why uh hikaru felt that if he
wanted to play for an advantage out
comes the move d5 the benefits benoni
like
with the pawn on e3 the noni players are
definitely happy definitely very happy i
mean it's still a binoni structure yeah
but foreign i think it's quite good
i wouldn't be able to explain yeah i
wouldn't be afraid of playing this for
black oh absolutely
d6 knight c3 e6 it's nice and unbalanced
and there's nothing really to be afraid
of compared to a normal benoni white's
gonna have to spend an extra tempo to go
e4 yes normally they go
exactly into this variation but with the
move e4 played in one go of course so
i'm actually i'm kind of curious about
what's going to go out because knight a6
was played by maxim and then knight d2
was played by hikaru all right and it
seems like this is exactly the main line
with with e4 the blind on e4
but there's no advantage of having it on
e4 you're going to have to play e4 at
some point i don't think that you want
to keep it on e3 unless there's some
reason
i can't think of a very good one i'm
looking at white's position and saying
well
down the road long time
down the road white has an issue how is
he going to get this bishop on c1 into
the game
and if you're not playing e4 it doesn't
have a very good view
and playing for a fianchetto is going to
take a lot of work because this bishop
is sitting on g7 in them in ambush
just ready to pounce on a mistake like
b3 we're gonna want to see how hikaru
handles this position i think he's
playing more on maxine not knowing the
situation but
meanwhile we have um maurice ashley with
an update on i believe the fabiano game
well it seems as we mentioned yesterday
that players with the white pieces have
been less ambitious because the main
lines seem to be all basically fine for
black and that seems to be the case in
that game you guys were just showing
there nakamura not wanting to go down
any main line grunfells that but he
knows
look maxine vacillarov knows extremely
well so let's just play some random
nonsense basically but this is not that
random and there might be some
durability to playing the game and let's
see keep going but let's take a look at
this one that is being played right now
between the world champion and fabiano
caruana and you talk about lacking
ambition if you got out of bed and had
to play this position with the white
pieces you guys would probably say what
the heck
i gotta play this it's as symmetrical as
possible the knights are off the board
it looks essentially equal as though
they decided they would just make a
quick draw
well not so fast earlier this year a
game was played between two players
arishenko and etienne bakro the
frenchman who is a very strong player
and white was able to win this position
in july of this year take a look at some
of the moves it looked very natural
black was probably thinking come on i'll
make any move and i'll be okay but first
things first let's just get a trade off
the dark squid bishops white has a
superior
bishop on f1 so this trade was his first
plus and already there's a little bit of
tension here at a strong rook on e5 we
go forward just a couple of moves and
suddenly white played the move h4
you thought white wasn't ambitious well
now clearly he is and in just a few
moves after
h5 was allowed and rook feat
queen to e3 and suddenly we had
troubling along the e line black went
down miraculously quickly after
domination on the dark squares by white
he slowly just kept increasing the
pressure on the position bishop c6 and
now h6 another
squeeze move after rookie five rook
takes e5 rook to d8 and then g4 this is
from that position we said it was so
unambitious
rook d6 queen e3 just to conclude the
game after these moves rook back to d6
and now queen to e5 and black resigned
here certainly a miserable game to have
to play why you might say well why
didn't he keep playing rook d8 allows
this move queen to f
six an embarrassing position maybe a
little premature the resignation but
still this kind of position can erupt
from what we saw way back here the
position that they are now in is carlson
and and caruana so there's no position
that you just say oh wow this is an easy
draw certainly the world champion has
this game on his mind and he has in fact
played the move has he played bishop to
f4 yes he in fact did play the move from
that game despite spending a bit of time
to think about it you know
he knows the game and he's got that
victory on his mind and he's got a few
thoughts so don't think that he's just
trying to make a quick draw
yeah that was a pathetic loss oh my gosh
look if you play chess be prepared to
lose it's just it's a part it's a nature
of the game if you want to be a diver
you know springboard diver you're going
to belly flop time on occasion i don't
mind losing and i especially enjoy
losing good games where my opponent
played brilliantly but losing a game
like that you know it just makes you
reconsider the whole idea of being a
chess professional that was way
way way off board too pathetic
poor etienne
bishop f4
okay i understand the squeeze i
understand the skills factor and i know
magnus is
you know uh he was one of the world's
best he was so famous for his positions
which had basically nothing yeah and
turned him turning them into something
but you recall i was having this
challenge to
yourself and maurice yesterday where i
said
look my whole career it was about
pressing with white holding with black
right this is not a position where you
would you know readily rub your hands
together and say oh great i get to press
it's sort of like the advantages are so
minute
it well it doesn't inspire me let me
just put it that way magnus wins this
game hack tip and all the rest of it but
wow um
too
too narrow for me you think this is too
much
i think an important point though
is clearly fabiano in no way in the
world looked at this position with any
kind of care i mean if he saw this we
should have said are you joking this is
dumb like i'm not yeah he just he would
have just just kind of looked at it in a
scan and said this is nothing i don't
need to study this if i get this on the
board and i lose then i'm just a loser
that's that's got to be his attitude but
magnus undoubtedly looked at this very
carefully because he knows that all the
hours fabiano spent preparing whatever
else he prepared and all the critical
moves
this is not a waste of time all your
preparation is a waste of time and you
got to be sitting here thinking what did
this guy cook up in this
boring looking position and magnus
confidently knows okay i've got the edge
at least in terms of the psychology will
it mean anything for the board that just
looks so drawn it's not even funny yeah
well we're going to have to talk about
yes
marijuana reacts because i mean
compared to other players in this
tournament especially the one that we
saw louis tianbaccaro who's a very
dynamic player he's very famous for this
king's indian type of position exactly
you know i i can see how he might not be
the best defender in the world but
karana can easily play as newsfest
boring
solid defense and no problem doing so
yeah so i'm wondering if this really is
the best technique against him we're
gonna have to
on the other hand if you wanted to make
a
positive
insight
from white's position it is true that
white definitely does have
control
well his rook is on the
open e file
so i mean uh black still has to
neutralize it's not like black can just
go okay i've got i'll play bishop f5 and
i'll do what the other guy did to the
other guy i will trade this light
squared bishop for this light square
bishop and i'll go h5h for him and
checkmate you on the king's side well i
don't think corona will play no
so i mean i'm saying
you still have to play a number of exact
moves and magnus just feels that
well it's tough getting an advantage in
other lines
this is safe maybe worth a try now it's
always important to realize that if you
ever trade the dark squared bishops that
favors white and just because of the d5
pawn
but it does seem to be a first instinct
that you want to trade off that bishop
right the bishop on e7 yeah you want to
go bishop f6 clear the e
file but then this bishop e5 right and
our final uh
game that we haven't looked at
it's interesting i've played in so many
round robin tournaments in my life
and i really recall those events where i
drew the number one i get
and i've done incredibly well i think
i've won every event where i drew the
number one wow at the lottery why you
start with two whites
and you finish the tournament with a
black it almost feels like you have
almost an extra two whites throughout
the tournament right and for vessel and
topolof he gets two whites in a row to
start the event as we know he lost
yesterday in a
uh
in a time trouble and uh he'll have to
actually fight to be on 50 with white
precisely
and how how is this uh the berlin uh the
curse of the berlin uh grisha alexander
grishok yesterday got the worst of it
against uh hikaru the reason was the
berlin player no i have always
associated doing with the white side
yeah
i didn't know he played it with black
d2d3 it's turned out that this might be
the most combative way to try to keep
the queens and uh bishop c5 c3 i don't
know you think apollo should have just
sat back and waited for carlson's idea
maybe he should have played the same way
yeah or maybe
uh i recall there was a recent game in
the european uh championship where it
was
magnus was white
against um lavon aronian and it had gone
castles knight d4
knight takes d4 bishop takes d4
and amazingly
a beautiful
game by um lavon ironian where he really
well no other way of putting it he
crushed they crushed him magnus carl
yeah yeah
it was great
so
i'm sure that game was fresh on uh the
top players minds and hence we have
three three
castles all of these moves have been
played
ooh
so a6
you know we should think of c6
okay b takes e6 castles rookie 8 rookie
1
and we have this position
for those of you with long memories i
remember mickey adams
playing the computer hydra oh and
there was uh
i'm just going to put a move on the
board it's it's not
their game but the point was that mickey
had a position that looked like this
where he ended up with these double
pawns
and the computer hydra
really made it appear
that this position was really bad like
these pawns
could be exploited and mickey never got
any initiative
with his two bishops so there is a
lurking danger that those double pawns
can
be a long-term weakness
and if you don't get you know your light
square bishop in the game
you're just kind of suffering a little
bit that makes sense maurice some
thoughts please
well you brought up michael adams and
i've been looking at the game between
geary and adams the opening that we saw
with the move bishop to d2 and right
here after bishop d2 bit queen takes c5
was played and of course b4 is something
you want to play but of course f2 is
hanging so e3 to stop anything and this
position here has not been played that
much and when it has been played i
shouldn't say it hasn't been played that
much actually there are a number of
games in this line but it seems as
though black is fine more or less in all
the lines the point here is that black
has to move knight takes on d2 now
making sure he gets those two bishops
and then after knight takes back
guarding the pawn or he could have taken
with the queen of course but the pawn in
c4 would be hanging but knight takes d2
and now this position here black has
shown himself to have many resources
that basically equalize i mean there's
one move to play d4 in this position if
you want to keep some tension in the
position dc4 probably being the most
liquidating move castles is possible as
well
black has also even played a5 number of
moves black can try and that might be
the rub the fact that black has so many
moves if adams has not looked at this
position then he's got to make some
choices and again we see just like the
game with magnus and caruana a position
that may be equal we see players with
white doing this more and more this
position may be more or less equal but
what happens if i drill down deep take a
long look at the possibilities and see
where the tricks are maybe there's a
trick trap maybe an idea somewhere and
forced my opponent to figure it out at
the board now great players like mike
adams he could solve problems at the
board for sure that's why you're a top
grand master but if you get behind on
the clock just a little bit in the
technique that players like geary
display
that could be just the edge of player
needs playing on the clock and
especially this little funky so to speak
time control that might prove to be
something that said
it does look pretty equal thank you
maurice
you know of all the world's top players
and you think about the history of world
champions uh post-world war ii
very very few of the world champions
really wanted to step into a benoni as
black
with the exception of michael tallinn we
all remember bobby fischer doing it in
game three
of the 1972 world championship match
essentially we have
the bononi with an extra move for black
and michael tall would be thrilled to
have the black pieces
there was a game i think it was from the
u.s championship
caden troph
was white against hikaru nakamura yeah
there it was a benoni by hikaru and
ikaro just played a model game of like
if you're black and a bononi i thought
he was in a little bit of trouble at
some point yeah but i'm just saying that
he killed him
with a very nice combination
so you know
i'm thinking you know in
modern chess theory the bonnoni is kind
of looked at askance as like a risky
line for black but if you're going to
give black an extra tempo i mean you
should be getting punished for it and
i'm just wondering
what the heck
uh hikaru who plays the benoni plays
everything uh is thinking he's going to
do
he's just sort of like gifting uh
let us say this extra move rook e8 or
this extra move rook b8 well there is no
sort of about it he's had he's he has
extra basically lost the tempo because
this is the main line of the benoni
exactly this is the
yeah and he has down the temple i mean
there's no
there's no other way i mean uh white
could have the move a2 a4 or rook e1
or i don't know even possibly queen c2
uh white white's missing a move
yeah there's no other way i don't know
which one he's missing but he's missing
one basically what he's saying is that
the benoni is so
bad that if you give him an extra temper
still playable i guess for white or he's
thinking uh well i got nothing against
your groove held i've got better chances
i'll give you an idea i'll give you a
free template just don't play the
groomfield exactly please stop it stop
it yes so okay having said that uh let's
take a look at what white white by the
way did play the move e2 e4 obviously
and he's thinking um about getting this
bishop in the game clearly on a very
very good day what white wants to do is
he wants to establish his knight on c4
he wants to bring his bishop out to f4
problem with all of that is you've got
to eyeball keep an eye
on this pawn on e4 make sure that it's
sufficiently protected
so while i'm not a big fan of this move
uh
f2 f3
there's some wild counter
attacking
ideas in the benoni that often go
like knight h5
and you've got to be just a little bit
uh sensitive to this idea that well
if the queen goes here and there's a
knight g3 kind of check made in the
position you don't want to allow that
and also you can't play your knight to
c4 too early because then you're simply
uh walking into a tempo with b7 b5
that cuts out the move f2 f3 is an
option yeah i don't like it too much
so
if you play a4 as a kind of a
preparatory move then notice that this
move knight on a6 which is kind of
flexible it wants to go to c7 and
support b5 you play a2 a4
a little bit too soon you just allow
black to take up a nice perch
here on the b
b4 square so a4 is cut out so now you
really need to start looking for a move
that will sensibly fit
into a long-term plan of how you're
going to develop the pieces i think
rookie one
rookie one is the most okay so rookie
won
so black's idea is definitely he wants
to play b7 b5
um
if i prepare it with the move bishop d7
um
i'm i don't know
can you play no i don't think you can
play knight c4 right away
i'll take
take
take
knight takes d6
and you're giving black this kind of
opportunity of playing rook e4 too much
activity of
so bishop pardon me i have to take that
move back so bishop d7
uh sorry i'm preparing b5
play a natural move like a4
okay now see the thing is that normally
yes after bishop d7 b5 is not a threat
because because you don't have a rook on
b8 right so i can usually just play
bishop f1 right and when you go rook
beat i play knight c4 therefore bishop
d7 is dubious right
right right
so rookie one uh and by the way bishop
d7 is not the only move knight uh there
are others
goes back into more normal things
well there is this uh funny
idea
that normally speaking positionally it's
great to have advanced our pawn to a5 in
a funny way black takes advantage of um
being in possession of the b5 square
right so i'll just put a move on for for
white for a second and now suddenly you
toss out this move bishop b5 but it's
sort of like dude you're interfering
with my grand design you know stop uh
stop making counter punching moves you
know
uh very interesting um
the benoni these lines of play i like
these positional uh strategic battles
so yeah i definitely interesting it's an
interesting variation but i think that
overall
white should be
unable to claim an advantage an
advantage once you give up an example
some thoughts as we
as we debate the pros and cons of losing
a tempo is white and a main line
again it's that point about white trying
to
just get some position
he believes okay i'm not better is
there's no question hikaru nakamura
understands the niceties of this
discussion it's not like he's thinking
oh yeah i i'm down a temple really i
didn't know that and he absolutely knows
that he's down in tempo and is willing
to go into this position and decide to
make maxim think and maxim knows it's
fine for him or ought to be fine for him
but we'll see whether or not he is able
to continue the game especially since
he's not in his normal territory in the
grenfell another position here
you know it's fun when you're
being a commentator you're trying to get
inside the minds of the players and why
would he play this particular line well
this line that geary our tournament
leader played against michael adams
position is so equal-ish and i say ish
many of the results have ended up draws
very few victories for white in this
line very few in fact only two i could
find in the database and after detail c4
bishop c4 castles this position white
has castled here however
the move the one game that was with a
strong player rafael well from brazil
grand master laytown were playing with
the white pieces he played the move b4
when this position was presented to him
and his point was to play with after
queen to f6 to play the move queen b2
and this line
this line was played by leitao he was
able to win this game now you wonder
what is the point here the point is to
put a knight on e4 and eventually maybe
get a knight on c5 also you could castle
here in this position and just play
chess this night and this these two
miners being slightly superior to black
miners is that enough to write home
about well gary's the kind of guy a
small edge is enough so it looks like
he's tracking down later channeling late
house game and the the most important
point about this is that they're playing
he's playing quickly and michael adams
is being forced to stop and think i mean
if michael had adams had known this
position he'd have played automatically
however geary again very confident
blitzing out moves blitzing out moves
somewhat like magnus carlsen in this
position he blitzed out the bishop f4
move sorry he took some time before he
played bishop before but once bishop f6
appeared on the board he instantly
played bishop to e5
just like that game we saw earlier
however a difference happened here
because bishop e6 had been played in the
other game
rook takes e5 and now rook to e8
avoiding bishop e6 and getting his
bishop into some kind of trouble so it
looks like caruana has sidestepped
whatever that preparation was and now is
forcing magnus to stop and think about
the position
different approaches we see here with
the white pieces but well before we go
into deeper detail on today's openings
we have a special as jennifer shahadi
was able to
catch a little
word with um laura's trent
hey guys thanks i'm here with
international master lawrence trent bon
vivant hello also works with fabiano
caruana
now we know you have a favorite in this
tournament but besides fabi who do you
like
well um we've got a lot of great players
here haven't we i mean you can't really
say that we're we're lacking
in choice
um
magnus maxim alexander i mean they're
all they're all great players lots of
excitement
so um yeah but you know i can't really
go for anybody else except my fabiana so
i'm rooting for him till the very end
even if he loses first eight games
i'll be there for the ninth well
actually i won't i'll probably would
have disappeared for the night but
that's not going to happen um
paulina cariana means something
completely different than that so what's
the opposite of pulling in carawan and
then this would be pulling a this would
also be pulling a caraway
what kind of camera we'd confuse the
terms i know you're kind of a
superstitious guy lauren so just don't
even go there don't say no
he'll be fine well speaking of fabio
what do you think about his position
today against lavonne and what do you
think of the opening
um well the opening was very slow uh it
was uh d3 spanish i think fabiano
probably prepared this
um he didn't want to go into a martial
gambit and uh levon's been doing well
with that with black so he's got a very
slow position but actually
past few moves his position i think has
improved drastically and i think he's
got a little edge now and it's one of
those edges that are you know a safe
edge where he can just keep on plugging
away without too much risk
and if he wins it great and if it peters
out then no big deal so i'm quite happy
at the moment so how do you feel about
such an amazing tournament part of the
grand chess tour being right here in
london
um as a british test player yourself
does it feel great no i love it i mean i
was here at the first one seven years
ago i remember i was commentating magnus
carlsen was here
he was only
18
and he played this amazing game against
vladimir kramnik i remember it very well
um and then he became world champion no
it's just great i mean to have all of
these stars here in london it's just so
good for for chess
for chess in england
and also there's the huge
um scholastic element of the event as
well we can see here behind us chess
sets
all over the place in the main lobby
kids tournaments coaching sessions loads
of side events no it's just a massive
massive thanks has to go to malcolm and
the team
um for putting on this event and also
people like peter davis for helping you
know without him this wouldn't happen so
no it's just uh i'm absolutely buzzing
to be back in london and uh
and be here for this just an amazing
event now
um with fabiano caruana without giving
too much away can you tell us what makes
him special that you've never seen in
any other player because i know you're
also friendly with a lot of the other
top players what do you see in him that
you haven't seen in anybody else um it's
an interesting one the the great thing
about fabiano is his style isn't easily
identifiable so you when you ask like
carlson he's kind of got this karpov
esque about him when you ask about
nakamura well he's kind of got this
dynamic edge with fabi is difficult to
locate start i think that makes him
difficult to play against on top of that
he's young full of energy and he has got
real determination to get there so
um very special guy i'm very very
honored to work with him
thank you lawrence tran international
master we just saw him in st louis and
it's always great to see you later it's
great to be here thanks for having me
thanks guys back to you guys in the
studio
you could fly to venice
or paris
or even copenhagen
you could fly all over the world
but why
when you could just come
to st louis
your trip begins at explorestlouis.com
so
we're back here
live with the london chess classic round
two and well we had a little bit of an
argument going
we're having a lot of fun during the
break alejandro because we're we were
making fun of hikaru nakamura's position
and i was arguing just a second
after knight h5 not only is black got
that extra move in a bononi but white's
setup is all wrong because completely
wrong
black has just opened up the view of his
bishop on g7 and he's ready to plant his
bishop either on the e5 or d4 squares
and we're this is exactly what we were
talking about and we were having this
amusing
amusing moment between ourselves
that after rookie won which looks like a
normal move until you suddenly oop
as mike tyson would say you get punched
in the nose or punched in the mouth and
just to illustrate after rook f1 the
move queen h4 com send
yes precisely you go
and uh checkmate is virtually
unavoidable after queen h4 and queen h2
that would be the end of the game that's
a punch in the mouth
so
we're sitting there wondering what on
earth
because hikaru who plays the benoni he
understands all the nuances all the
little tricks yeah he hasn't played in a
while but i'm sure he hasn't forgotten
yes exactly how to dynamically play what
used to be one of his favorite openings
defenses yes exactly so we're sitting
there
uh
wondering what the heck is going on in
this game maurice we're going to come to
you and i ask the same questions what
the heck is icaru thinking
i have no idea
this is just not a lie
he gets paid
this this losing tempe seems strange and
also the fact that the engine is
suggesting the move knight h5 uh which
which you know it's just like
obvious clearly obvious giving energy to
black and the bononi i was a benoni
player myself until white kind of
squeezed enough that i said okay that's
it i gotta get out of here
but if you're just going to give away
tempe thank you appreciate it so we'll
see what he's thinking there but however
on another board someone who's not
squandered the white pieces is our
tournament leader anish geary and look
at how he has improved on previous lines
remember we said in this position this
was looking somewhat equal-ish except
the difference being
the minor pieces white has slight
superiority of his miners not being
constrained although you look at this 9
on d2 and you might say well it doesn't
look that good well take a look at this
move he played bishop d3 no castling
and after six the move queen to c3 we
had talked about queen to b2 was that
idea in the late tile game but queen c3
is geary's fine point what's the deal
here well he's got adam's thinking the
natural move is bishop to d7 but
suddenly the move b5 appears on the
board and this knight has no forward
squares the queen being on c3 stops the
knight from being able to go to a5 and
the knight will have to grovel on some
ugly square d8 or b8 and already the
engine's saying very nice position for
white so geary has investigated a
sideline seems equal not great results
came up with just a small wrinkle in
queen c3 a nice little novelty and it
looks as though he is going to get an
edge and adams is starting to realize
that there is a bit of poison here and
the last thing you want is to play a
position that you thought should be
equal to suddenly start to look worse
and his clock ticking away geary
blitzing out his moves and you see him
walking by there a very dapper young man
in purple i remember
i wore
the same i wore a purple shirt and tie
at some other broadcast and he tweeted
he tweeted at me and said man you're
stealing my clothes
uh it sounds like you know
i'm sorry young man you're stealing my
clothes yes
at any rate he's looking good right now
in the game
how do you feel that's always a good
feeling when you're just walking around
the stage you haven't even started to
think because right well your opponent
has spent about 40 minutes you're still
in your preparation right just waltzing
around the boards casually watching the
other games
oh without question uh
i
was quite unlucky in my chess career
probably because i was too lazy to
actually do great preparation
and it wasn't
all that often that i really caught my
opponent in some really good preparation
but those times that i did
and you know like you say just walking
around and enjoying my opponent's
discomfort as he's
at the board you know furitively looking
for a way out
it is great that's that's when you know
you you you're well prepared and uh
anisha's
that little tiny wrinkles of b4 and
queen c3 has put
the veteran mickey adams under a little
bit of pressure
uh due to that idea that maurice was
mentioning
right b5 and
i was looking at this uh ending that
mickey adams might think about going for
queen f6 it's not that i'm very unhappy
about the double pawn so much as this i
really wasn't happy about
sticking my knight on the eighth rank
so you coaxed the double pawns
that can white
apply uh
screws further
there was a wonderful annotated game
in the new in chess magazine
written by anish geary where he played
against grand master
peter laco
of hungary
and got just exactly this four verses
four two verses two ending
yes
where uh he won a real model game in
this ending against peter lego a very
very hard man to beat by the way yes
extremely solid actually i remember that
a lot of people thought that match was
going to go nine drones nine draws and
suddenly it was onish gary winning in in
the two games right
and this position
is very unpleasant because this bishop
on e4 lords over this long diagonal
making it very awkward for black for
example bishop d7
and maurice was mentioning that it's the
activity of white's two minor pieces
before black literally gets off the
starting block that is giving mickey
adams problem so
you think you could bail out into this
uh ending this no no no no it's not a
good deal it really is not a good bale
and actually mickey came up with another
idea he decided to play the move a6
which
looks like a little bit of a weakening
move i mean i'm always worried that a
knight's going to land on this b6 square
one day
i was about to suggest the move a6 and
the reason
was was that after the move queen c3
i'd love to play the move e5 if i have
trouble the other way developing my
bishop well let me bring it out on its
natural diagonal let me open up a
pathway to get my bishop out it's just
that this move b5
attacking the knight driving it
backwards knight to c4 it just feels
like white's getting
going here there's there's an initiative
in the position for white
that i didn't want to deal with so hence
i was thinking well why don't i start
with the move a6
agreed long term i don't want to lose
control of the b6 square but maybe for
the short term it's the best
opportunity for black to
um break out well and if i play knight
c4 in this position how are you going to
respond okay
well i was a little worried about that
move because of bishop e4 actually oh
sorry i thought you were going to jump
right away but bishop e4 i see
i wasn't just
just to mention it's not that i missed
knight b6 i just wasn't so worried
about losing this bishop at all right
but bishop e4 is by far superior move
now and now i have an issue right um yes
you do
obviously i'm staring down bishop takes
c6 and
this pawn okay so
let's say
and for my next trick
well i'm not a happy camper uh
alejandra i thought i could take on c6
here now right i might be miscalculating
but let's give it us our world i want to
take with the knight yes and then play i
understand rook g1
and you have evil intentions don't you i
never said i was against
i'd better kick uh
well if i kick then i can simply retreat
i think i can also go knight f3 i think
that's really nasty yes uh and that's
came
over look at that wow
uh
yeah i don't see how you defend the
bishop the knight is very conveniently
placed on f3 you prevented
e4 yeah after rook c a queen back to b2
that's all i'm stuck yeah
that's an extra piece
and i played very logical moves yes and
i i i end up
that's a very nice line obviously i had
put my faith in bishop
uh takes
g2 i may have to play this but down upon
i mean you will be suffering
i know i know i'm a big yeah
i uh
it it
it really is about this king for the
moment if i don't immediately get an
initiative or some kind of compensation
you just have to make one move though
before we'll leave this position alone
if you do take on c6 and i was planning
on it and you were oh wonderful well
then i will go
pardon me rook take c6 yeah queen v2
probably right and this is the moment
where i have to do something very
uh initiative like whether i take the c
file or play rogue jesus
and go in after the g2 pawn yes
so let's say queenie for castles
and i'm a little bit worried that my
initiative
is not quite enough right right
it doesn't feel like i
i'm i'm there yet
but if i do it the other way queen e4
castles rook c2
this might
give enough yeah
at least it's at least it's it's better
than the linear i made it on g7 isn't it
so
there is a pull there is something nice
and again it's that small nagging the
long term plus
uh i just wanted to turn back to the
game of magnus carlson because i think
that's a a hugely important rivalry not
just for today but for years and years
to come
we've almost
what else can we say we were kind of
almost berating
the world champion for his choice of
openings but after the move queen b3
again it's like black as lagging right
and black is trying to um
equalize
bishop b5
what do we got what's magnus's idea is
he does he want to
jump on the e file the problem with the
e-file is that once i play bishop e6 it
seems like there is no reason for your
rook to be
on this particular file but i don't
think that it's advantageous for you to
be on the c file either
i'm going to play rook c8 on the next
move and you definitely have a lot less
pressure than for example the game
arishenko
where there were four rooks on the board
so
all right so bishop b5 so again after
queen d6 you're not impressed by
white's command of the e file
uh in the straight bishop ending that
should be nothing right i was just
thinking about that actually if
everything comes off the rooks come off
the queens come off how's the bishop
ending with the weak pawn on d5 and my
initial impression is absolutely nothing
for white dead draw that draw
the reason is it's just there's no entry
squares for white's king no interest
whatsoever yeah and even if there were
it wouldn't even be convincing either i
still would not be convinced yeah
okay so it
it appears to our eyes at least that
this trait of rooks was extremely
important and quite beneficial for black
as magnus is still
squeezing but just maybe very slightly
it's attack he might want to play a very
quick rook c1 queen c3 utilizing the
fact that the background is weak to try
to create something all right but let's
say we'll see
uh so you're saying we're going to meet
bishop e6 with queen c3 hopefully i was
trying to create something i understood
i understood
uh
and after for example f6 queen c7
something along these lines
and we're forced to go down into
obviously we just talked about the
bishop ending so
we'll walk into this pin
and can black make hay out of this
i don't know if he can win but he can at
least play bishop f5 rook b3 i have to
stop this killer move killer blow i want
to say
so rook c3 i mean at the very least
after rook d1 i should probably be okay
yes rook d1 is good enough
um
yeah
and of course looking at it from another
perspective i didn't have to play f6 if
for example there was some kind of
checking and
or something yeah i could have taken f8
or age six or some other kind of move so
uh
you talked yourself out of it you wanted
to go rook c1 and queen c7 and by the
time you got there then you discovered
it was a dead end i'm trying to figure
something out yeah right right you want
uh you want magnus to show
an initiative some gumption here but it
just
doesn't seem to offer no i i can't see
too much i mean you always have also
queen f4 ideas
i mean
uh potentially turning the tables and
right
yeah there just seems to be a little bit
too much activity for black and it's
small but it's sufficient in this in the
sense that you always have rook c8 to
counter on the c file right you always
have queen air force to counter it on
the d-pawn it felt like in the back row
game and there's a very key difference
in the backroad game black never created
anything you know because of the four
rooks the four rooks were clamping down
the position yeah he weakened himself
with g6 which allowed white to play h4
h5 and after that black was completely
tied down to the defense whereas here
even though black's passive that's no
there's nobody arguing that the
potential to actually create a threat
it's very very ready it's very ready
yeah very small yes maurice you have
some thoughts to share of uh round two
of the london classic
well as the leader of the tournament
anish giri tries to make a little bit of
a grind in his game we'd like to reflect
on yesterday's exciting game that he
played against vasily topolov that was
absolutely a topsy-turvy affair it
looked like topalov was the one who had
all the chances but then he allowed gary
back in the game and then the critical
moment appeared right here after bishop
f3 if you haven't seen it
let's just review this move bishop to f3
attacking the rook trying to chase the
rook off the rank and then knight to e4
was played and in this position if
topolov at any time at all he absolutely
would have taken this knight why because
there's so many moves from it turns out
for black that are just fine he didn't
take the knight he took on a7 and
according to the engines
rook d7 easy draw chasing this queen
around perpetual chase on the the queen
because f2 needs to be defended also
what would be fine is also rook takes f2
according to the engines even that works
out much more complicated fashion but if
you've got two choices that at least
equalize you know if topalov had some
time on his clock he would have looked
and said oh wait a minute i can't let
any of those on the board it turns out
that it was the third choice that was
actually crushing knight takes on f2 and
we got to see this position a full rook
sacrifice after bishop e2 knight takes
h3 king kf1 down a full rook was geary
to go into this line boley had to see
the next move queen to d5 beautiful
geometrics controlling all the squares
now the night guarding the dark squares
the queen are guarding all the light
squares the entry was inevitable and
after this move bishop h5 which was just
a try in time pressure kingy one gave
better chances to fight back but still
he would have lost in that line as well
and then it was just hammer blow after
hammer blow with check king d1 knight f2
check king to c2 and the knight e4 and
the king's just going to march up the
board with the queen chasing it followed
by the rook and it's going to be mate
geary called himself lucky but queen d5
that's not luck that skill those of us
looking at the game didn't even see the
move coming down with the analysis after
king f1 it was quite a scintillating
move a move he should be proud of and
i'm sure one he'll remember
for the rest of his chess career
oh yeah that's going to be all right we
got we got the outfits going you know i
gotta say i like his i like the
intensity of that shirt that purple is
very good but
you know all right we got the memo
who wore it better.com
who worried better yeah we can state
your opinion yeah
but also i just want to emphasize that
what happened in that game especially
from onisha's point of view was
the clocks were ticking yes i mean it's
easy for us in the studio to sit down
and say okay this was a really nice
geometry
wasn't easy because i remember saying
king f1 wait what do we got what we got
yeah and you're really confused he's
down to just a few minutes for quite a
number of moves and he came up and he
discovered the
the tactics
it was very impressive very impressive
i've turned once again to the game of
hikaru nakamura we have been waiting for
this move knight h5 a very common uh
thematic move in the bononi
in what black often tries to do in any
binoni kind of structure is to trade off
at least one pair of minor pieces
if he can trade off two black is often
doing very very happy so this move
knight h5 has a dual purpose number one
it wants to hunt down
and on a good trip good day trade itself
for that bishop that's a nice idea
secondly you want to play the move f5 so
uh
for example let me just show one very
common
theme hold on that that's not a good
move
um otherwise i would play knight f4 well
rookie won hold on that was the
checkmate variation
we're still stumped and whatever
okay okay
right we are still stumped on white i
think that's why knight b3 wanted to be
played by well the computer wanted
knight b3 and we just recoiled
because ib3 looks ridiculous because in
a benodi white never wants to put his
white wants to put his knight on c4
and just
to again boldly state the obvious after
knight c4
b5 it's a
marvelous initiative for black this is
a dream as a dream benoni
does have the move f4 however we should
look at that f4
is an important line and it looks as
though bishop d4 check looks quite
strong
uh but after king to h1 the knight on h5
is hanging well how do you respond here
against simply queen h4 are you actually
going to take you should take the engine
takes instantly bishop takes on h5 and
and trade again and go into this
particular end game but i always thought
the seniors were actually quite good for
black the engines seem to really dislike
black's position because of the double
pawns right and they're like oh my god
double pawns on the h file right then
you realize that there's a little bit of
initiative e4 is weak in the long term
you always have knight before coming in
the light squared bishop eventually
becomes a problem i mean i wouldn't be
too afraid of playing this unless the
issue here is knight b5 right very
confidently i was about to say unless
there's a specific problem and it does
seem like knight b5 this
is the problem yeah exactly and it's a
lucky thing for white that he does have
this move knight b5 right again whenever
you see this
knight h5 bishop takes h5 you're force
of forcibly reminded of bobby fischer
well again during that break that we
were having we were having this
discussion and well
having a little fun with each other and
i was saying i think white's going to
play f4 and you recoiled you said what
is that you're going to play e3 then
you're going to play e4 then you go then
you go to s3 and then you're going to
play after you didn't believe it for a
moment not only do i not believe it but
it's on the board
f4 f4 is on the board hikaru nakamura
has just played f4 we're going to have
to see how maxine vasherla graph reacts
it's a very interesting move knight f6
would represent the loss of a tempe but
currently the knight on h5 is hanging so
he actually has to do something right
and what's weird guys and what's weird
is we now i'll jump to that board
i'm looking at it we were laughing at
you know pawn went e3 e4 now f3 f4
the thing is
if you want to justify this play with
bishop d4 check king back and then the
move knight to f6 white has this weird
move again knight to b5 very sharp move
and the point of the move is that he is
attacking this bishop the a7 pawn is not
really on his mind although hey we might
take it but his e4 pawn is a trick he
wants end games that are good for him
does white so let's take a look for
example at at a move that's natural
knight takes on e4 it's not entirely
natural given that your bishop on d4 is
something you don't want to give away
this great benoni bishop and if you look
at this trade trade trade down and now
bishop f3
and suddenly after the rook drops back
white can play the move b3
put a bishop on b2 and i think all of us
would say uh wait a minute this is not
what we were looking for so that's not a
natural continuation that works anyway
now let's take a look at the other line
after knight b5 the line is this move
bishop to e3 challenging this knight
trying to knock the legs off of this
pawn and again not worrying about a7 at
all but a surprise is in this position
to move knight takes d6
surprising shot why because after queen
takes he now has this move thanks to the
bishop being on that square knight to c4
he'll get this bishop back from from
from
black and again we get that position
where white has the two bishops and a
past pawn and i think even much more so
you wouldn't like this position with the
white with the black pieces so
this problem of bishop d4 going into the
position looks very normal looks very
natural did nakamura study this position
and say
yeah this is actually good for me and
it's an easy trap to fall into if you
don't spot it coming and he's gotten his
moves in and the other move of course
knight f6
although he's lost two moves playing e3
e4 f3 f4 knight h5 knight a6 is just a
loss of
two moves as well so an interesting
little dynamic taking place here
nakamura seems
very comfortable right now
is he still in his preparation no i
don't know i think that this position
just
i'd like black let's let me be very bold
about it okay so after f4 yeah i agree
with that by the way those are wonderful
tricks bishop d4 bishop e3 and how
with the knight b5 as well as a knight
c4
black's position gets refuted but we all
understand that there's a certain spirit
of the bononi not just the benoni
there's a spirit of the grunfeld you got
to play c5 and you've got to sacrifice
pawns on occasions
when you're playing black and the bononi
you just have to
take a very ornery position you have to
say i'm not backing down i'm not going
to lose the initiative you want to take
my knight be my guess i'm going to play
f7f5
which fits the spirit of the benoni so
basically i'm challenging
i'm making a key
key challenge
on the e4 pawn now if you take the
knight which probably you shouldn't do
by the way but if you did do that and
followed it up with taking the pawn
i'm just thinking okay
this is what we do in the menoni we
activate our pieces
we try to do things like knight b4
knight c2 bishop d4 check knight d3
and even at the cost of a pawn perhaps
even two are you sacrificing upon for
the initiative i'm not because i don't
play with you but i have to you know if
i get there
who are you you know
if you feel me the cards you know you
got to play what card you you know cards
you you're you're dealt all right well
in this case i'm sacrificing pawns i'm
going to see if maxime actually does
this it's very enterprising kind of
position right but he might be as you
said forced to do so we're going to have
to compare there's a compulsion
compulsion propulsion yeah we'll take a
little break and we'll be back and see
if maxime after his thoughts actually
plays the move f7 f5
so
so
welcome back to the second round of the
london chess classic we are well
underway here the opening is very much
over and we're getting into the
nitty-gritty of the middle game here in
london as we have some positions that
are definitely more interesting than
others well we've been having some
spirited discord discussions during our
break
about the spirit of the benoni and this
idea the combination of f4 and knight d2
in the game of hikaru nakamura the us
champion versus france this is number
one mvl
it's still controversial i mean even
though we've been picking on hikaru i
can tell you that after i see the move
knight f6 i'm warming up to kara's
position why
because
uh
of
the possibility of e5 we see this um
very often
in a lot of benoni's
that for example after a move like
bishop f3 not the only move but just i
want to put some uh moves on the board
for just a second b5 which you would do
when the bishop runs away you're going
to get a4 for free i will definitely
play a b5 exactly and now you're going
to go knight b5 and virtually
unstoppable move for white is to then
continue either with knight takes d6 and
e5 a tactic
that maurice actually pointed out in a
previous position or simply e5
and um
i can see
that
white's position suddenly you know all
of his pieces bloom you know it just
it starts to look
uh suddenly like wait a minute where did
black go wrong and why is this position
suddenly attractive uh for
um white well i'm gonna have to disagree
okay please
take it uh i simply don't like the
combination of how to tighten d2 with
the harmonious idea of playing e5
because precisely you want to play the
move e5 it seems to me that the knight
on d2 is just horribly misplaced it
would have been better off where it
started on f3 as it was for example in
this variation that you get
b5
okay let's say that
and this is of course very theoretical
sure sure uh it didn't happen it won't
happen
yeah
with the idea as let's say that
eventually getting into knight c7 and i
understand that right now my pawn on uh
a7 is hanging so i cannot do this but
just for argument's sake let's say that
i i managed to trade off the uh the
knight somehow okay with knight c7 i
defend a7 and i get to trade out the
knights what is your follow-up how are
you going to develop the pieces in such
a way that you're going to either allow
yourself to play e5 or knight c4 to
prepare e5 problem is that i think
it's going to take you too long
okay what what's going on in my head
we'll make a move i don't know if this
is a good move or a bad move i tell you
just to show you what's going on in my
head
is that i want
to sacrifice the pawn i want your rook
to end up on the square e5 so that
everything suddenly just comes into play
this knight on c4 which
yeah i agree the night on d2 but
suddenly you put the night on c4 this
great blockading night you pick up a
tempo
and you know certainly trust me that no
grand master is going to
be so compliant no but also no grand
master will retreat that rook oh i think
they will always sacrifice it on d5
like instantly i think like right now or
like you just go for rook takes d5 oops
sorry uh my mouse is not
there we go i got it uh rook takes so
you've got two pawns uh foreign exchange
para bishops pair of bishops and yeah
it's true that your knights are well
placed but i mean they said enough
compensation and again we're we just put
it we're just putting in movies yeah but
the
you know i've always felt that bononi
when you enter the waters of the bononi
you've got to be prepared to play
sharpie and you just can't sit back and
take the punches you've got it you've
got to be throwing the patties as well
and this is the type of position where
you know if white doesn't play
these initiative creating moves like e5
and knight c4 and be willing to
sacrifice the pawn
uh things can go
wrong king h1 yeah useful
you know just
tucking things away so there's no bishop
d4 check yeah there's always some checks
in this variation plus a great amount of
grief
so this is not a very surprising move
not at all okay and at the same time you
are eyeballing the b5 square so you're
not making it you know
a slam dunk that black is going to play
b5 right okay bishop d7 what else well i
was thinking knight c7 bishop d7 runs
into knight c4 which i have to calculate
i'm not so sure it's a good move right
because
or
this is again one of those uh variations
where
like you're saying you're so ready to
give up your exchange when
when the bell rings
because also don't forget this knight on
d6 you know it's vulnerable to sudden
tactical shots
so this doesn't get a variation i mean
okay so
knight c4 probably premature maybe
premature still has to be calculated to
the end there's some ideas of queen b3
at the end but let's assume that it is
premature we go a4 right now i'm saying
is black black wants to establish his
knight making it that much more
difficult for white to play e5
kind of positions i just think that
black is relatively okay i think well
black is more than okay
that's why
wasn't that great a fan of the move king
h1 i thought i was going to play bishop
f3 and just go for it go for it all
right um so that's a very very sharp
position that can blow up literally at
any single moment well kikara will be
trying to put some pressure there with
white meanwhile let's see if magnus
carlsen is able to actually do anything
against fabiano caron as maurice
actually has an update for us in that
game
well certainly
explosive developments on that board if
i may use the word explosive
but take a look at this position
that they played after the move bishop
to b5 karana sidestep and said no
problem i'll give you a pawn you want
the pawn take it he obliged with playing
queen takes and now a6 bishop back to d3
of course you can't take this pawn now
because of mate so he played bishop to
e6 queen to e4 now threatening the h7
pawn and the move g6 and essentially
saying now i'm hitting your b-pawn i'm
going to play rook d-8 and hit your
d-pawn i have bishop f5 in the position
so surging ahead with d5 allowing bishop
f5 queen e2 bishop takes queen takes and
queen takes b2 regaining the pawn right
now after queen takes and now rookie won
and here's an a2 pawn no if white
allows this which i'm sorry he actually
is allowing it if queen takes a2 it is
black who is up upon and these are two
connected past pawns at that but white
has upon that it's very quick already on
the fifth rank ready to go down board
he certainly has some back rank issues
for the moment he might have to fix but
the move d6 is very interesting
is he
better here enough the engines are
saying that white is equal here the
position is equal it's not so easy to
get this pawn to go all the way down the
board as you would like and move like
queen to a5 for starters tagging this
particular rook and he's going to look
for some queen exchange queen five queen
b5 if you're gonna change off queens and
bring his king over this one is going
nowhere fast and it's black who's going
to get anything if if this position goes
that route so
seemingly a dynamic position
i say dynamic the position still looks
pretty dead ish except this is this is a
trick i mean it should be equal black
should be able to defend but look a6 and
b7 those are real pawns on the board so
make note of that position it's
certainly getting interesting another
position that i'd like to look at
is this one
aronian versus anand aronian won the
sinfield cup he's definitely in a good
position to win the grand chess tour now
that topolov has lost his first game as
well this game we saw started out quite
unusually with the move bishop to d2 i
did some research and found this is
actually how nakamura played against
aronian with the
ronion had black in that game when they
played a match right here in saint louis
in november of last year in this
position castle's e3 aronian playing the
move rook to e8 proceeded to lose the
game to nakamura anand played more
principally with the move c5 attacking
the center of the board and after a3
traded giving up this bishop and now 94
quickly getting the bishop back
immediately quickly to knight takes c3
and now bc3 an unusual move for this
position queen c3 is most often played
in what is already an unusual position
because bishop d2 is not that popular
and knight d7 instead of the knight on
c6 and these moves were played very
sharp position very interesting at least
lots of stuff on the board anand being
very confident bringing his
his knight over to f6 rook b1 showing
that his intentions are on the queen
side pressuring this position and after
this lockdown move knight e4a for rookie
we now see this move a5 white trying to
make hay on this side somehow trying to
prove that this bishop on d7 is a bad p
i'm sorry on c8 is a bad piece because
he can't just simply go to d7 because of
queen takes looks like white has a bit
of an edge a superior bishop and a pawn
structure seems to favor him slightly
but isn't enough to defeat someone like
anand we'll see the time situation is
good for both sides and finally another
game to look at
grisha versus topalov we call this the
seller game but in fact only topalov has
a loss in the entire tournament richard
drew his game so he's doing fine so far
drew his first game it's apollo both of
them fine on the clocks as well the
players are getting the memo about the
clocks and play quickly
this position very rich very interesting
black seems dynamically placed moves
like a4 can come and eventually doesn't
seem as though too much danger here so
very rich games all across the the hall
all
every game is interesting in fact
including this one which you thought was
getting a little bit snoozy so we'll see
if the games proceed in this interesting
fashion in the next hour
thank you maurice thank you maurice uh
let's take a quick look at the standings
that we have after
uh the two two tournaments of the grand
chess tour so vesseling topalov who is
the leader after
the norway and st louis tournaments well
he lost his first game so he's gonna
have to make up for lost ground asikar
nakamura he had a good chance yesterday
to go into the lead but was unable to
capitalize still he's number two in the
list at 16 points levon ironian trying
to press against anand right now is 15
points magnus carlsen well he still has
some chances in today's game against
fabiano carrana don't count him out yet
he is at 14 points and a win in this
tournament he desperately wants to
finish the year with two victors in a
row he would like to win here in london
and go over to the strong qatar masters
and win that tournament as well
and what are they playing for they're
playing for a lot of money wrestling top
has already accrued ninety thousand
dollars as well as levon ironian with
their victories respectively in norway
and st louis and they will be playing
for a lot of money also in this
tournament right the bonus uh basically
uh 150 000 split between the top three
finishers i think the bonus pool is
going to be divided 75 000 of the winner
overall winner extra 50 000 to the
runner-up and 25 000 to the third place
finisher and that is on top of the
prices for the london chess classic
itself which is 300 000 very very very
nice
uh going to the
game between cariwana this was the match
up that i thought
especially a year or two ago we're going
to see the rivals that these two top
guys
magnus
and fabiano fabiano still has to
win and to become a challenger
i'm reminded of the game that i actually
played with walter brown essentially
very very similar i had it passed
an advanced pass pawn
in just a major piece ending and i was
two pawns down a pardon me a pawn down
as we could see easily see
these
a6 and b7 pawns
and i had a position where i could
actually press
being upon down
right
so because of the initiative that this
pawn gave you the passer right and i
could uh
play
uh
with uh
the idea of making threats of d7
making threats with the rook coming down
to the seventh rank so i'm kind of
keeping black honest he has to keep f7
both f7 and b7 protected actually i won
against walter
not because of the position but just
because
uh
the pressure of my various threats uh
took walter into time trouble something
that he uh very famous
very famous for
and it actually ended up being very
costly for him so
even though the computer might say all
the positions are draw or what have you
i can tell you as a human player it's
really easy to slip and to fall into a
losing uh tactic yesterday general
concept in chess do you feel there are
certain positions where material is less
important than others so for example do
you think that in heavy beast endgame
specifically queens and rooks or queen
and rook
having
an extra pawn is definitely less
important than for example other end
games where
the initiative is not as costly for the
defending side oh yeah and i haven't
ever really came up with an overall
universal theory of when those things
are true when does a pawn become you
know colossally important versus you
know
having a fortress or a proper blockade
but i remember a very nice
line
that alexander alekhine wrote in his
memoirs he said
when i was a pawn down in a queen ending
you know my my chances of holding the
game were really really bad
then his opponent won a second pawn and
as a chance has increased because he had
a passer himself and when his opponent
won the third pawn then i knew i had to
draw because my opponent had to give me
a perpetual chat right like he had one
pawn as compensation but it was a passer
that advanced further and further while
his opponent was nibbling pawns he got
to a position where you better give a
perpetual chat and again a queen end
game and a queen ending right that's
right it always feels like it's very
tricky when there's still queens on the
board it doesn't really matter how many
pawns you have it's that extra passer
that important uh pawn that holds
everything together because the queen is
so good at pushing pawns but it's so bad
at holding them back right yeah it's not
a great uh blockader but wow
uh
good offensive uh play so i'm thinking
that
while a draw is a likely result
you know there's a lot of play now from
a practical point of view do you think
he would actually take the pawn or do
you think he would rather stop this pawn
as soon as possible play rook game
immediately uh yes exactly i think from
the practical point of view he would
much rather have a blockade where the
pawns not on the d7 square right so and
like that a2 pawn yeah it's not really
running away maybe it even makes a lot
more sense i know
counter intuitively but it might even
make a lot more sense to come back
and just stop the pawn in its tracks
before
anywhere you know i like that move a lot
actually that would have been my
top choice my top choice if i was better
especially if i was playing wisconsin
the position may require may require
queen before a more human approach i
mean
yeah
it does seem like a more logical way of
stopping white spot if you go rook d1 i
can stick my queen on d6 then i can
pressure the pawn on d5 i can simply
push my pawns on b5 a5 later they
obviously won't be as dangerous as
they're not connected past funds but
they should create enough distractions
to at least hold the draw yes agreed
so i agree that queen b4 is a very very
practical choice
i wanted to talk turn to the lavon game
be for a second
because as i saw the way i look at it
and i play the rugosin uh line myself
after a5 you have to be very very
careful as black that you don't
fall for a situation like this let me
just put this kind this is really really
terrible
but
here what happens is it's a knight
versus bishop again uh
and a trade that
maurice uh
likes to focus in on hone in on that
this knight on e5 is actually just a
monster knight not only is the c6
square a potential weakness but as is
the c4 pawn so you really want to be
careful as black that when white decides
to make that trade bishop takes e4
you've got to be in a situation where
uh
you can respond with queen takes e4
right uh sorry so what happens is
vishy wanted nothing to do with that
variation that makes sense you drop back
with a knight very quickly to d6
uh defends the b7
in order to release the bishop uh for
active play whether it be on the f5
square or the e6 square
i like white's position here it's
it may not feel like much but slightly
better yeah it's more
it's more comfort it's comforting for
white that he's got ideas like knight
well i don't even know i mean he could
even play for the old botvinnik
e4 yeah it just jumps to mind i mean
yeah it is slightly more pleasant to
have an idea to play for yes whereas i
think that well black might trade the
bishops but even after he does that he
doesn't have a specific plan he's just
kind of waiting
around hoping aronian can't really make
any progress right i'd rather take white
in this position yeah it's
more like you're trying to hold in
trying to seize the initiative so
erroneous maybe with a slight press in
this position but he's not the only one
today yes maurice actually has an update
for us in the geary game
actually a very important development
has occurred in that geary game our
tournament leader anish geary he seemed
like his novelty with queen c3 that idea
of binding black on this side was going
to allow him to get even more pressure
and a couple of moves after a6 castles
bishop d7 knight to c4 seeking out that
b6 square that seemed to really confirm
that impression however after rook b8
knight b6 rook fd8 rook ac1 pieces
develop
bishop back to e8 move like that a
natural solid move but still not an
impressive square for the bishop but
check this out bishop to e4 expanding
his game looks like very freeing
position for white michael adams came up
with this very nice move knight to a7
using that a7 square that he created
with the move a6 to now start thinking
about the move knight to b5 looks very
obvious like he's trying to go on this
square and now geary played a4 and as
soon as a4 appears on the board the
engine say your advantage is gone
instantly the engines did not want to
see a4 instead they prepared they
preferred moves like g3 or even queen to
c5 offering a trade but a4 seems as
though now white has maybe grabbed too
much space and there are a couple of
moves here the most principle one the
engines the queen d6 but the secondary
move bishop to c6 which i like better
personally challenges bishop on his long
diagonal get ready to bring the knight
back into the game and trades don't
really benefit at all to benefit white
at all this kind of attack just doesn't
go anywhere after the move knight back
to a7 surprising move making white think
about what is happening to your pawn on
this square you might think something
like queen to a5 is good
it turns out that it's perfectly fine to
play excuse me to play this move knight
to c8 just challenge the knight and
that's going to be the key move guys
after this move bishop to c6 if you just
drop the bishop back that was my first
instinct drop the bishop back what's
wrong with this position well black can
start to actually play for the
initiative first of all queen g5 what
are you doing you're threatening mate
really seriously okay what's go what
gives and now we get back to this move
knight to c8 as soon as you see it you
feel like something is not quite right
for white this trade is clearly very
nice for black the initiative on this
side has dissipated completely the a
pawn is hanging now that the threat is
on this knight so that's an issue and if
and this kind of position is just
meaningless i mean just trade you lost
all his real edge here and it's black
who can maybe just play rook up very
clean position no problems at all so
that move a4 seems like he has allowed
uh
adams to let go of the rope now in a
nice situation and adams looks very
comfortable at the moment in fact he's
instead played it looks like queen to d6
which as i said was the engine's first
choice earlier queen to d6
on the board now and this the engine is
saying it's just fine for black as well
so i think a4 represents a slip
by
by geary now this move is important is
attacking the knight remember the pawn
is hanging and that a4 move may have
just been biting off more than he can
shoot
it's kind of weird to think that
a4 is an overreach it seems like the
most natural prevents
seven from coming out into the game just
seems so natural it makes me think that
if you had such a
normal looking move on the board be a
slight mistake then probably white had
close to nothing even though his
position was very optically nice yeah it
was like one of those advantages is
maybe more
visual visual and really yeah absolutely
intriguing and a4 just one little
pawn move the difference of having the
pawn on a3 and a4 where the where the
pawns are protecting one another uh can
be the difference between having a big
advantage and nothing it seems like uh
geary
will have nothing but adams is such a
patient defender and actually we have
the players over in london had a few
things to say about each other oh cool
resurgence aggressive aggressive
dangerous never stand up during the game
original exchange sacrifice
pre-retirement time and just enjoying
chess
decent
bullet unpredictable
weird i would say
as a player for me sharp wild aggressive
tricky
aggressive uh and also
too passive at times
uh creative very solid positional master
prepared witty
tricky classical
lucky
resurgence
uh solid amazingly talented uh
positional player cocky
future contender
yeah
dangerous
myself
legend
ageless
solid
legend unknown
wisdom
difficult opponent
not just me
uh inspired a french maestro
quick
wizard french
my good body
talent
unstable
machine
the master of preparation tough very
focused academic
serious
good rant plan
i can't do myself
perfectionist blood's genius comfortable
blitz artistic unpredictable russian
grinder technically sound spider also
souls
elegant spider
british
underdog
that was a wonderful clip i really
enjoyed that i like that yeah i like
especially when the players refer to
themselves like already like me
right
no okay i think the players have played
each other quite a bit i don't think
there's a single match up here that we
have that's never happened before oh
that's for sure no yeah i think we had
the experience yeah i think only in
norway we had the opportunity simply
because jean ludwig had the
wild card but it hadn't so much
experience right but i think pretty much
everybody has played adams before who's
the only
possibility of having a match of that
summer happened before right
so uh
well a
very very tough round i must say today
uh i can't really pinpoint anybody has
as having a serious advantage at this
point so if you had to take one position
in the entire round you have to sit down
and you're going to play that position
which one would it be
okay now i have to reflect on it at the
moment onish gary's position
uh
you know i i'm basically thinking that a
moment ago he had more opportunities to
grind than he has
you know again i had this wonderful
experience with walter brown having a
past pawn
that
really influenced me so i do like
magnus's position at the moment i
don't think it's winning
or a big advantage and i'm a little bit
surprised that uh
fabby played the move rook d8 i thought
queen before queen before it was logical
right the most logical
and the game that actually has the most
uh firepower on the board has got to be
the hikaru game uh because it's a board
full of uh
pieces
crazy things i didn't answer my question
black might
if you have to chose this game would you
rather be white or black because i would
definitely take black in this position
i'll take white
grace what about your opinion
well just on alert guys this has
happened on this game after queen d6
geary played the move knight to c4 and
adams responded with queen e7 only to
see gary play knight back to b6 and
queen d6 on the board uh did they repeat
again it looks like
knight
that queen e7 has happened twice knight
has gone back to b6 and now the queen's
back to d6 looks like they're repeating
moves it looks like it's going to be a
draw and there he goes the handshake
they have drawn that move a4 was
definitely not his finest moment for
geary after that preparation adams
played very solidly and held the
position so far the
british grand master drawing two games
and
see seemingly pretty easily and with
black in both games not a bad start for
the home crowd favorite michael adams
for an underdog he looks he's looking
good a pretty solid i mean he's known as
a very solid player you've heard the
players themselves talk about adams and
well he's shown today that gary may come
up with some shenanigans but he's going
to be well prepared in his technical
game and he was able to beat back any
kind of pressure that gary wanted to
but
it's tough first of all uh to be the
wild card is a tough uh challenge
because all of the elite players and
you're going up you know like every
round you're playing a magnus carlson
you're looking for a break in the next
round no you're getting a vessel in
topolof thanks for coming
and the wild card taking the 10th
the number 10 you know starting with two
blacks so you're going to have an extra
black throughout the whole uh event
i mean it's really really a challenge
and right now uh mickey uh has faced the
challenge impressively making it look
easy
he has indeed
so the most enterprising game with all
the pieces on the board nothing
technical about this game whatsoever a
lot of tactical opportunities for both
players
dynamic to the hikaru nakamura game
against mvl
when we have left it we saw this move
king h1 knight c7 very standard
a4 uh
keeping the uh pawn from
popping out to b5 a7 a6 i insist
uh pardon me are we
are we up to date after 86 so i thought
a5 was played yeah i thought we had an
a5 and so again this is a very standard
idea from bl from white's point of view
he wants to get in this um
ampersand to
even though
you get rook takes c4 well okay after
knight
here you're gonna get ideas of knight
takes d6 and e5 and so normally speaking
you don't play b5
rather you play
bishop to d7 followed by bishop b5 or
even knight b5 i don't know did we give
up a little too soon on that party i
apologize did i after a5 do you think b5
takes rook takes or knight before no
rook takes takes knight c4 and then b4
yes all very standard stuff just a
second and i want to think well maybe
you do have some kind of uh e5 move here
but if you don't
maybe it's playable well let's see
because it's so yeah it's so uh forcing
so you got to take you got to take it
okay might be d6 and because that's
right it's resource
it's that black's position suddenly
doesn't look so good you're gonna be
able to take on e5 right after knight b5
i will probably recapture with a pawn
which opens up my rook i can write
and this looks pretty dangerous
big time because uh knight is jumping to
c4 and all kind and everything's kind of
rolling with the tempo
so which by the way doesn't mean it's
completely over they're still going to
be yeah as we know the icing amount of
possibilities there for black i wouldn't
be able to surprise the black somehow
okay due to some technical tactical
details i remember some games of vessel
and topolof where he seemed to play the
bononi and just literally provoke his
opponent to have what looked like a
massive attack and by the time you know
the wave had gone
what remained was really a tough
position and
vessel is right back in the game so even
though
he has a lot of life right even though
those positions we advance d6 and e5 i
don't want the viewers to think oh yeah
well it's just much better actually
that's still a very complicated position
and you might assume as a natural chess
player that you got the center you push
by black's pieces but somehow it ends up
collapsing onto itself a lot of times
the e5 pawn is very hard to hold on to
if black manages to for example
sacrifice the exchange in order to
defuse a couple of threats here and
there manage to capture the central
pawns he'll be in an excellent position
agreed but of course i do agree that in
this position after a5 the more natural
move is bishop d7 yeah you slow play it
but it's not really slow playing either
because every move
um
the initiative
you know if
for the moment the spawn on e4 really
looks like a tower of strength but it
could easily become very fragile very
fragile but this knight on d2 blocking
the bishop on c1
white has some issues he if this bishop
were for argument's sake allowed the
illegal move bishop g5 you might take a
fancy to white's position
if white does nothing then black starts
to play the move like a nothing move
would be for example h3 black starts to
play bishop d5 and suddenly he's
beginning to feel like wait a minute my
e4 pawn really is uncomfortable yes yes
and uh
so
white has to play it sharply now and uh
but on the other hand for a player like
hikaru he welcomes those types of
challenges as well he's ready to play
sharply but
he's got to
be precise and and
do it well and how do you think he's
going to be able to do that for example
here after bishop d7
i mean i want to play bishop b5 on my
next move i challenge you to finally
move
exactly uh and it's a it's a tough one
i play something like bishop f3
i'm so i mean i just
i mean i really really want to play e5
and i really really want you to play
rook takes e5 so that i can go knight c4
and bishop f4 or bishop g5 as we both
understand
my my problem is i don't have a good
answer for knight takes d5 yeah so i
need to that was why earlier in our
discussions i was putting my bishop on
f3 so i could do that type of thing
here i've really got a problem um
the knight c4 we've discussed this on
previous occasions
it looks to me like black would embrace
such a position especially very e4 d5
hanging in this particular exactly
so
uh
white faces a problem uh
and i don't really have a good answer at
the moment i think
i don't
i never really like this queen on c2 in
such positions because not
for the reason of
bishop b5 but for the reason of knight
b5 and i'm just encouraging you to take
a leap of faith
right you're jumping into my position so
oops sorry
so one more go let me see what else i
can do
a while ago you wanted to make the move
rook e1 to reinforce the move e5 so let
me give that move a shot for the moment
let me go rookie one at least with the
idea if you go bishop b5 i'll sidestep
your bishop
and play bishop f3 the idea of e5
yourself again um
i'm not completely convinced by this
either there's you know a bishop you
know the bishop just kind of takes roost
in the middle of the board you're going
to go knight b5 maybe c4
um
yeah
very so somehow i believe in black's
transfers
yeah it well overall it doesn't make a
great impression on me uh white setup
for the moment um
finally let me let me try it one more
time let me try bishop f3 which by the
way i can simply transpose into bishop
b5 unless you want to eliminate my
bishop that's what i was thinking about
i don't believe you i know i know i
should be fine i don't believe me either
you know
let me be the first to say that i i do
have the issues i haven't answered all
the
challenging questions you've been posing
maurice yeah thoughts we'll talk about
challenging questions you know this end
game queen
and rook with past pawns versus queen
and rook and potential pass pawns very
tricky one if you have the past pawn in
this position you probably don't want it
to be the d-pawn well if it's the d-bond
anyway
well the problem with the d-pawn is that
it's right in the middle of the board
why is that it's close to this king this
king can start to come closer and
potentially influence this pawn's
progress and it makes it very difficult
now let's take a look at a line the move
was played that was rook to d8 attacking
this pawn and the engines thought greed
was good what was wrong with queen takes
a2 in this position the reason for this
capture is not just to grab a pawn but
to make the defense easier or at least
the attack harder this pawn is not going
to queen easily and so white will get it
blockaded and then white will have to
once this pawn is fully blockaded we'll
have to make some kind of advance on
this side in order to win the game what
do i mean by that well let's go to a
different line with the move rook to d8
d6 is playable here and that's actually
what happened in the game and before i
look at queen takes a2 well actually
let's look at it right now quintesse 2
is a big problem for black because of
the move queen to d4 suddenly guarding a
critical diagonal and suddenly black's
counter play is not so easy if black
goes after this pawn it'll turn out h4
will show up on the board and you can't
touch the pawn if queen takes of course
we see rook down and on rook takes the
same the problem here is if you stop
this attack now rook to e7 and suddenly
you're busted you're dead this queen's
coming into f6 this pawn is untouchable
in fact the engines are giving queen
takes d6 as the only move giving away
this check idea because the position is
so bad already because the queen six
threat is coming in the position so you
can't touch the pawn now this d6 move on
the board by magnus so queen takes a2
would be a mistake by fabiano what could
he do though queen to be six is one move
going after the pawn and now the move d7
not the most precise rook d1 but i want
to show this point d7 is good because
now queen c6 i mean this is good for
black queen c6 stopping rookie eight
that was the threat and now threatening
the pawn directly so you have to defend
this pawn and now f6 comes in and this
is what i meant the king is now able to
come closer to this side of the board
and start to influence this pawn even
though it will be checked away from the
pawn if it ever comes to the e file it's
because of that influence it's not as
easy for white to get his game going
because he's got nowhere else to look at
and especially this pawn we're not on
the board at all then clearly black
could start to deflect the white pieces
by pushing his pawns down the board this
is the kind of position the engine was
looking at to say this will be
defensible for black get rid of this
pawn and then just rush your pawns this
d-pawn will go nowhere because you can
firmly force white to defend it this is
just the problem of having these two
pieces if you had another one like a
bishop he could stick here or something
nice a knight somehow a knight would
wouldn't get it done but some other
piece it would be easier or maybe
another rook on the board but not here
it is firmly blockaded so this we go
back now to the game position with rook
to d8 d6 on the board yes he can go he
actually has to at some point go passive
because his pawns untouchable and for
white he's trying to just squeeze a
little bit but as i've shown because
this king is close black is still fine
in the game as a matter of fact if queen
b6 the engine is giving rook d1 just to
make sure this king doesn't get that
close even if you block a with the move
rook to d7 just to make sure this king
doesn't easily find its way over to
aggress this pawn still should be a
fairly
equal position
but it's magnus and we know how he is he
will press and press with you not being
able to change the position too much we
could be here uh
another three or four hours
let's see how it goes uh maurice before
i let you go i just wanted to ask you
the engine's opinion on this um
game
between hikaru and mvl
very difficult for me to
coordinate white's
aggressive intentions
how would the engine evaluate uh such a
difficult position because we like black
over here and so does the engine so does
the engine they think that black is
definitely better there are a couple of
ideas here bishop f3 is the engine's
first choice
e5 was its first choice earlier uh to
play just to play very sharply but it
looks like the analysis is showing that
black is better in those lines nothing
to really fear although my suspicion is
that nakamoto's gonna analyze e5 like
all the way down because that's his kind
of move bishop f3 does look a little bit
like a wuss move frankly just guarding
this pawn and the engines are very
comfortable after knight to b5 saying
this position is great easy for black to
play undermining this pawn and
it's just a benoni down moves it looks
like you can't get your
your mojo on in this kind of position so
black is perfectly fine here as is black
in this position as well this grease
trick to paulov it's the grand
chess tour leader in topalov having
lost yesterday with the white pieces and
not proving anything at all today again
with the white pieces but we've seen him
do this before i remember that was it
the sinkfield cup last year where he
lost two games early and then bounced
back in one two topology was the kind of
guy that is always optimistic about his
chances even if he loses he knows he can
always win there's always a chance in
chess until the very last round so
maybe a good idea just not to get in
trouble in this game look at this rook
on the rank the knight is attacking he's
got the bishop he's got a pass pawn does
black the engine's like black in this
position this pawn going nowhere firmly
blockaded allah nimzovich your favorite
yes sir
on the square a3
yeah i was about to say that even though
that game between
uh grishok and topalov and grisham
pardon me did explode it was like a a
tight
nipping tuck game i was thinking that
now was a good time for vessel and
topoloft to bail after the position
opened up
maurice you're mentioning that this
bishop on c8 the spawn on c6 has passed
and this rook on a4 is excellent if i
was in topolof shoes i would play e5 and
bale hoping for a line like for
argument's sake takes
knight takes and i'm just going to put a
move on the board for the moment i must
play c5 excellent move thank you
c5
uh rook to c1
you know
the rook on a1 a super
passive i want to say so rook to c1 rook
takes a3 rook takes c5
and a handshake and escaped the playing
hall thinking well maybe i slipped
somewhere and
i don't want to lose
two on the truck just make one more move
because i think i think we're under
sofia rules right 30 move
well the sofia rules is just simply no
draw offers uh i think there are a lot
of uh tournaments that have a move
requirements such as the us champion so
this is a move requirement as well yeah
so they've got 30 moves so they would
need to make one more
and they would make several more so yeah
and they find a repetition that this is
a draw yeah this looks like a drawer c5
was played on the board i mean i really
expect rook c1 you don't want to allow
black to play bishop e6 and then c4 and
then suddenly start thinking of being
better you want to cut that as soon as
possible absolutely i think we've seen
when we played and i do expect a draw in
this position we're going to go ahead
and take a break right now and see if
the pilot decides to bail out with rook
c1 all right and we'll be back shortly
welcome back to the second round of the
london chess classic the third and final
tournament in the grand chess tour while
we were on break we did get a result the
expected draw between vesseling topalov
with the white pieces against russian
grand master alexander grischuk it was
something that we saw coming we thought
that topalov would play rooksy one take
off that c5 pawn not let grishok
actually get some chances on the board
and that's exactly what happened there
was a draw nothing to do about it and we
are left with three games
one of them which we also expect might
end in a draw in the magnus carlson one
magnus carlsen also the lavon aronian
anand
game
looks very uh
static state if you will
the
most exciting game is actually between
u.s champion hikaru nakamura and mvl
today's round feels a bit of a letdown
yesterday
although there was four draws they were
impactful they were fighting draws
today's games looks like the players are
just playing too cautiously if i can use
that expression
ironically
uh
we felt that yesterday's win by anai
shigeru is almost like a forced win you
know uh vessel and topolof said you know
you've got to make a sacrificial
combination and uh anish gary said fine
and it worked really well
today in the game of hikaru nakamura
hikaru said i'm not going to let you
play your grunfeld i'm going to force
you
force you to play bononi
a tempo ahead mvl said fine
and
basically hikaru's been outplayed
by his opponent uh in a benoni where he
hikaro is facing some serious issues
yeah so far we definitely like the black
pieces not only that he's down a tempo i
also never felt that he really had this
coordination in his pieces that the
structure demands normally i always see
this structure with a bishop on d3 right
knight on f3 ready to go e5 and suddenly
we have a knight on d2 that's been the
bane of white's existence for a while
even though he put it there very early
it's been wanting to go to c4 exactly
ever and it's still not able to do so
right because of the weakness of the e4
pawn and we see
very clearly that this knight on
b5 very well closed
placed on b5 is actually
ready to go to an even better square in
the center wonderful outpost knight
coming to d4
and
once you see a knight like that in a
benoni where you have the f4e4d5
structure you know you've done something
wrong absolutely this knight on a6
suddenly transferred itself to this uh
primary square
d4
for example just to put a move on the
board for white i'm not suggesting that
g3 is a good move i'm just making uh
an opportunity to step back
then this bishop could also route itself
to the b5 square which again just
puts the kibosh on any knight c4 ideas
that white is entertaining
and the initiative all
suddenly is in black's hands as we know
absolutely when it goes wrong in a
bononi it goes wrong
you want to go knight g4 pardon me i i
can't do that because well gosh i can
almost do that i mean but okay if i just
put my bishop on
uh
mission three three actually threatens
bishop c2 trapping the queen isn't that
terrible and even now uh black might
just even play a move like b6 all the
initiatives all the all the ideas no the
people has to be very careful and who
knows it better than in carl himself
because he plays the bononi uh with
black and he knows all of the
strategical themes and the tactical
themes and when things go wrong it
really goes wrong and this is a bad
position and i wanted to point out a
couple at least
before
i was thinking about the move knight c4
in this position taking advantage that
for once the e4 pawn is protected and
hoping that after knight takes c3 maybe
i had some kind of resources but just to
show you the resources that you might
have been
in the past right when we got to such a
position
we we were stumped by the move rook d4
right and
thankfully now black doesn't have it
right but still but still here i think
after bishop g4
uh sudden uh attack
but the problem what you wanted to say
with the knight coming to c4 is not that
you have to take on e4
but
you've got an issue
uh facing with bishop b5
uh pinning this knight uh to this rook
and
even after a position like knight takes
d6 queen takes d6 e5
we we talk about what's left on the
board the remnants of the position
and boy black's bishops make a much more
healthy impression than does white
c3 is hanging the rook on e1 is hanging
this looks really really bad really bad
a super initiative for black so hikaru
nakamura facing uh serious problems
with white
again something i mentioned yesterday
maybe it's a theme i'll keep hammering
away at uh the elite players are not
showing
uh edges uh an edge with white it almost
seems like black is having thinking
about the berlin especially of nakamura
yesterday yeah what's going on
it seems like black's doing very well in
certain positions i mean we haven't seen
any great novelties i think in the past
couple of months that really show me wow
white really refuted this variation
blacks in real trouble it seems like
black's doing great i mean this approach
of losing a tempo and going into benoni
clearly backfiring despite what might
happen later in the game you know even
if mvl gets outplayed or even if mvl
somehow manages to lose this position
for some reason right it's very clear
that the opening did not go the way that
hikaru wanted i mean even if you told me
that hikar wanted to just fight in an
equal position this isn't equal no no
this is already slightly better for
black this is play for black and uh
during our break i was
talking to maurice and he reminded me
that there was an interview that he had
here at the sinkhole cup with hikaru
nakamura where hikaru said look i'll
tell you something
everybody's looking forward to the
candidates don't expect that in london
they're going to show their best stuff
and we were like oh what are you talking
about million dollars
in prize money the players are going to
really wheel out the best stuff
was he prescient and
are the players occasionally
keeping things in their back pocket
because at the moment i'm not impressed
well we were talking about this with
maurice actually over the break and it's
interesting
to see which players are in the
candidates that are also playing this
tournament and so far the players that
are confirmed to be playing in the
candidates are nakamura karwana
but it seems almost impossible that his
rating average will drop below
he'll be invited he'll be invited so
he'll he'll be topalov and then theory
is almost also first certain he'll have
to lose every game in the in london yeah
it's not going to happen and aronian was
given the wild card right that's part of
the announcement so it seems like we
have a few players that are actually in
the candidates but we also have an
interesting mix of players that will not
be in the candidates right i wonder if
that's gonna adam's right that's gonna
change things up and we see some players
for example mvl i mean he's not afraid
to show anything right and he's black
here against icaru decides okay i'm not
going to go into what might be your prep
because hey mvl's not afraid of showing
his hand right he has nothing to play
for in the candidates he's not
participating so he might as well play
the strongest groomfield he has
meanwhile if hikaru for some reason
found some novelty against the groom
field which as unlikely as that is the
group of being the groomfield right uh
well he's not going to show it here
okay well
but whatever the discussion is i'm
telling you
i'm not impressed with the white
the handling of the white players by the
elite well speaking of not being very
impressed with the white pieces we do
have vesselling topolof who started half
out of two with the white pieces with
jennifer shahadi from london
thanks guys i'm here with bessel and
topalov and we didn't get a chance to
talk to you yesterday so tell us a
little bit about what it's like to be
here in london and you know as a
grandchild store leader
well uh
of course it's nice but so far
i'm not playing well
i hope to to improve in the next games
but i mean it's not like
something tragic is happening but of
course
the game i lost yesterday was it was
completely unforced
so
obviously it's my fault but still we
have seven rounds to go
but that was a tough move to see queen
d5 right oh yeah but uh of course it was
not practical uh from my point of view
to go for all these complications
because
that was
why it was not really risking to win and
there was too much risk to lose so
it was just a big mistake but a lot of
your fans like about you that you're not
always practical well but that's uh it's
very good when uh it also
it's also connected to the result
when you also win but uh when you take
risk and you lose then it's not fun
got it all right and what about today's
game anything interesting no not really
i think it was a correct game but
i think we made kind of natural moves
and at some point we changed all the
pieces so it was a i mean especially
after yesterday i think i needed a game
like this you know just to to score and
not to make
big mistakes to play quickly not to get
into time travel but of course so far
two white pieces and
only half a point it's not a good result
obviously all right well good luck in
the rest of your games and we will be
talking to you again soon
back to you guys in the studio
thank you jennifer he doesn't look happy
man no i mean look he's the number two
player in the world former world
champion he uh there's the drawing of
the lots before the tournament takes
place so he's got a couple weeks to
prepare he know he has two whites to
start the event actually several months
because since the sink field cup he's
known that he's going to start with two
whites okay and so he's got these two
whites and he's got a half a point to
show for it no no no no no no
this is uh well he didn't express
disgust
but i'm sure yeah he wanted to
express his self disgust right
not good not good no and again uh has uh
hikaru found a
solution uh what is the
clock times
he's
40
behind on the clock and he's but
considerably actually he only has 40
minutes for 23 moves which might not
seem like the biggest of deals but
considering that he's been playing quite
kind of slow he had a lot of time
pressure yesterday and the position is
complicated and more than complicated
difficult to play for white house
precisely precisely that's the problem i
would say the time starts to become an
issue right
right
that is exactly the point
uh
i would tell you that i would not be
happy about the move g3
knight d4
and it's sort of like one of those
things
i just wanted to point out that uh
amongst human players you could
spot the this repetition
and boy hikaru would probably be so
happy to escape with a repetition i
would be more afraid of what i would do
after the move bishop b5 than i would
with the bishop g4 but you know
grandmasters they keep those uh
they they keep that awareness about
repetitions when they uh could occur and
yes sir we're not gonna have to worry
about that no we're not gonna have to
that is for sure and uh e5 was played
actually yeah but this was okay hikaru
played the move e5
basically because
he didn't see anything else he needs to
you know throw caution to the wind here
he cannot sit
there and allow black to just improve
the knight on b5 to d4 the bishop on d7
to b5 yeah but how does this work so
let's take a look yeah so things happen
and instantly hikari took on e5 and i'm
assuming you take with the brook there's
no other move on the position right
you can take on c3 first
there might be a a reason somewhere down
the line that you want to take on c3
first but it seems let's just assume for
the moment that right it seems unlikely
that you want to throw in knight c3
because you always have the chance of
playing knight takes e3 with the tempo
yeah and knight takes b5 will never help
white
knight c4 basically box now you're
hoping that you're going to pick up a
tempo
over here
and you mentioned earlier
that you felt in such positions it was
always uh meaningfully good for black to
give up an exchange so let's just hang
around
rook f5 to stop this bishop from coming
to f4 for just
a moment and and move like g4
huge legs slam down rook f3 in a
nanosecond and be super super happy
uh but
rook f5 stops bishop f4
ikaru might think to himself please
please bail me out of my
problems you know like allow me to make
a repetition
um if you drop back with the rook
uh then this pawn on on a5 becomes
useful because we've got an idea of
bishop coming to f4 and if the rook goes
to either the a8 or the c8 square we've
got knight b6
so we see
that this liberating move e5
one that i've been trying to get in ages
ago
so i think there's a lot of
possibilities we still have to consider
i particularly like for black rookie
bishop f4 okay knight c3
ponte c3 bishop b5 but we're going to
have to take a look at that just as we
come back as we have anish giri from
london with jennifer
thanks guys and with anish geary who
really thrilled us yesterday today he's
coming off a draw against mickey adams
tell us a little bit about today
well yesterday everybody got a little
too over excited so today i decided to
to keep it real and and place i usually
do but in fact of course
i
i was happy with my position from the
opening because
well it's symmetric but i have some
pressure and i managed to in a few games
recently in a similar type of positions
the bishop was a long diagonal but
he played
quite precisely and i didn't really
figure out
how i'm able to keep on the pressure
because i have this knight on basis
which restricts his rooks but
after he removed all these pieces it
ended up healing nothing
so
yeah there was a very short amount of uh
moves in
during which i could have
i probably would have to look for an
improvement but the way i played turned
out to be quite harmless and then
uh after that
well when i repeated the moves i i no
longer saw a way to
put any pressure although
well the game should have definitely
been a bit longer than that
so yesterday you had such an exciting
game your adrenaline must have been
really high was it difficult to go to
sleep
no
but not that exciting let's not
exaggerate
uh it doesn't difficult to go to sleep
but
i'm trying to play you know every game
uh independently from that as you can
see
but okay you know it's i think it's
coincidence that yesterday and today is
uh so different just uh somehow
uh the type of position today it suited
me well but um
yeah you know in such positions where
you play for a very small plus you have
to be extremely precise because one in
accuracy can cost you a half a point and
the game can be end in a draw right away
one last question what color are you
going to wear tomorrow
do you mean the
well i know i'll play with the black
pieces but um
that's all i know about the colors for
tomorrow it's always a surprise i see so
yeah it's your wife's choice yeah
usually yeah today she she had to play
herself in the open group so i uh so i'm
probably messed it up but yeah i'm
trying no you did well you did well good
job
thank you back to you guys in the studio
he looked good he looked good
maurice gave him high marks
while we were listening to that
interview uh anish was explaining that
uh he had won a number of games recently
in exactly such such structures
and he is technically extraordinarily
gifted
and here we see the resilience of the
veteran mickey adams as well because
mickey held that comfortably and i i got
the impression from the interview that
aneesh felt he had something and he
didn't know when he lost it right when
it slipped away and it was that move a4
a4 yeah that slipped it well and
speaking of mikiano's we have him with
jennifer shahadi
thanks guys i'm here with mickey adams
and today he had a draw with anish gary
uh tell us a little bit about the game
were you happy with the result um
yeah i'm in a draw with back as a good
result i mean annie she's always tricky
in the opening somehow he's always
coming with some
idea and uh again i was sort of thinking
a lot
um it looked very scary somehow the
knight of b6 but in fact i don't think
white is actually
doing that much problem is the note on
b6 uh doesn't really attack anything
although it
is a bit awkward so
actually then
you know i was a bit concerned and then
suddenly it was just an immediate draw
so yeah i was quite happy
so did you feel like a lot of pressure
before that that moment how does it does
it really change your demeanor over the
board or is it like the same kind of
thing
yeah i mean it was just awkward because
there wasn't a really kind of clear-cut
solution it looked very strange to play
a6 put another pawn on a light square
that is knight into b6
um but actually just uh in the somehow
at some stage when i'm getting to go
bishop eight knight a7 i'm threatening
to change the light squared bishops and
uh and it all simplifies it just kind of
looks scary
so today is a big day for the london
chess class because it's the first
weekend day and we have all these uh
these kids who are not only in the
auditorium observing but also
participating so what do you think about
that
no there's a huge amount going on here
with all the uh coaching the lectures uh
well the british british knockout
championship is still going on the open
tournament so there's really
well we just had a freeze there a very
interesting conversation with mickey
adams as he's describing all the
festival activities and unless you're in
london you don't really get that sense
and flavor
just how many activities are going on
during this event it's really an
exciting oh absolutely good event we're
happy that you guys are joining us here
in the live commentary but if you
actually have a chance to visit one of
the super grand tournaments the grand
chess tour the candidates i mean it's
it's once in a lifetime the environment
in this event is thrilling the aries
electric on the playing hall i always
enjoy going to these events and just
kind of breathing in
yeah some good chess yeah exactly it's
osmosis and speaking of good chess
i think you were channeling mvl
uh because of the number of previous
analysis that we have been making about
the hikaru mvl game you kept
hitting the hammer
that often times black is very anxious
to give up an exchange to get an extra
pawn and two bishops and open up the
position and after this move knight e2
by hikaro which isn't the great
follow-up that you want when you play a
move like e5 yukari's sitting there
saying i don't want this knight to come
to d4 bam
uh varasang is the dutch would say
surprise rook takes f3
challenging
suddenly
the very foundations if you will of
white's position you want to recapture
with a rook because after all you don't
want to expose your king after gf3 but
then suddenly bishop d5
big
big time pin
or bishop g4 pardon me uh big time pins
on uh
this diagonal but the d5 pawn goes so
you're going to get two pawns oh yeah
and uh
white's pieces are going to be scattered
and thrown back
g takes christmas
is no great shakes either for white
because now bishop comes to h3 which was
just played with a tempo when the rook
moves again we're going to see knight
takes d5 two pawns
powerful outposts for blacks knights and
great bishops i mean no sorry this is
not good i love black's position but
right unfortunately there's a grand
master that does not agree so much okay
this rook takes f3 and that is maurice
ashley
uh i was wondering why you're referring
to me here
it was look i love moves like work f3
don't think it's personal moves that's
the kind of move you just play
coming straight out of brooklyn you want
to shock them first and then ask
questions later but the the thing is i
keep looking at this guy and this engine
is saying that actually after 92
there was a better move knight to g4
a simple move just what are you going to
do knight g4 very flashy as well the
point being that this knight is not
really hanging because of takes
takes check of course and takes and then
bishop takes on g4 and it's just a
straight pawn for no reason now i admit
this is definitely not as sexy as rook
takes f3 and this is the kind of move
you want to see happen in the game it
gets it lively but he has to be a little
bit careful just a little bit careful
that he keeps his advantage
all the way through because after bishop
to h3 rook to e1 which was played in the
game now you want to be careful here and
not just necessarily grab this pawn
precisely because after knight to f4 the
position is getting a little bit too
stable even though this bishop is
fantastic don't get me wrong but it
looks like trades are going to happen
here that you don't necessarily want
trade of queens could happen and those
rooks start to look a little interesting
so for that reason for that reason guys
in this exact position the engines say
do not take this pawn and instead play
this
hyper paradoxical move remember the
knight was there before it went back to
f6 now not taking the pawn back and
putting the knight on this square now
you might say well now why not knight f4
anyway well now queen to h4 and black is
building some energy on this side but i
don't think you would predict this
position as the one you were going into
when you sat the exchange on f3 so a
critical moment here with rook to e1
that knight d5 is not as fantastic as
all that and queen takes on the square
is an end game that is better for black
but again the move knight to f4 here it
comes and
yeah
gotta like black's chances two pawns
two bishops this bishop's still strong
black is certainly for choice here but
white
might try to fight you here just just
might this bishop and this knight coming
to d4 does look very nice no question
about it
but maybe more
simple was the other idea of knight g4
so i guess it's a matter of taste in
this position
certainly in all directions it's black
for choice
yeah but having seen the results of what
uh your uh maurice has shown as my
knight f4 i'm convinced uh
my opinion has changed and knight g4 was
simply stronger rook f3 was flashy
and uh does give black an edge but
imprecise and precise uh it's just that
uh when you get this move knight f4 and
you realize that a lot of pieces are
going to get trade thanks to the tempo
against the bishop on h3 suddenly the
open files the rooks have their say i
mean so
uh as i'm sure mvl just saw rook f3 in
95 and kind of shut down and said that's
good for me
not being fully aware that well after
more trades
uh why uh white has stabilized this this
disadvantage if you will and i'm sure
he's thinking about queen takes d5 but
he's not the type of player that would
shy away from a knight h5 i mean that is
for sure and by the way that paradoxical
you bet that's part because you know
you're thinking to yourself you want
you don't want to see this uh
run this pawn this d fight pawn running
for a touchdown right so your uh
instinct is to eliminate it not just to
allow it on the board but on the other
hand uh
bringing the queen to h4 there are some
problems on the king side i mean queen
h4 is coming it attacks the knight on c4
which is a relatively important point
yes and sometimes knight g3 will just be
completely lethal yes that's right as
well so uh
knight h5 i do like that move and
theresa further thoughts
yes now a position that seemed to
maybe heat up a little bit but then just
suddenly got squashed as a game between
carlson and caruana we saw this end game
we should go back d6 rook d7 very solid
g3 and then queen of six eyeballing the
pawn remember we talked about this idea
in these end games this pawn just gets
mercilessly attacked it looks like
you're tying down black's pieces but in
some ways white is tying down his own
pieces because they have to defend this
pawn so black is blockading looks like
stasis queen to e5 grabbing the e file
and now queen a3 stopping a move like b5
from happening because the a pawn would
hang and now a5 saying all right what is
your plan i've got the position
perfectly blockaded and
what is there to do this pawn is not
going anywhere at all
f4
whoa
exposing the whole innards of the king
right here look at these diagonals but
he's got everything covered for the
moment e3 by the queen so c5 by the
queen and d4 as well but what about
queen to e2
attacking the rook
queen back to c1 did carlson play and if
you take on a2 don't be crazy queen c8
check will happen well we don't expect
fabiano to make that kind of mistake
queen to e6 now we're back to the same
story
the pawn is blockaded he's got the e
file it's even better in fact after the
move f4 he's got the ifa paul's
blockaded and what white's king is
always under threat of perpet there is
no progress to make it probably queen d2
would be the most natural move guard
both pawns and then black's gonna start
pushing his pawn so there is no edge his
f4 move this game is looking more and
more like it's going to be a draw now
this position is really interesting
well really in air quotes
because
at least black has gotten something
going in the game between aronian and
anand he's traded off queens has gotten
a g5 move and
perfectly fine for black now the b7 pawn
is not going to be any kind of long-term
weakness especially since another rook
could come here so doubling rooks won't
matter and it's actually black who's
trying to make something happen but very
difficult to see how progress is going
to be made so we've seen two
basically quick draws another one in the
carolina game this one maybe-ish
not definitely the most exciting round
and we're going to count on this game
as it gets a bit wild based on this rook
sacrifice which may or may not work out
in black's favor
thank you maurice just a a comments to
two comments to be made about this uh
ending of magnus and fabi
uh first of all i would never even cross
my mind and i'd slap myself
i would never play the move f4
just because i would be fearful that
uh there'd always be perpetual checks
and just exposing the king is a major
queen ending it kills your chances to
win yeah it's really uh an extraordinary
move that's comment number one comment
number two
is as black in such positions
it's always it's always a very important
resource and a very good move to get in
uh you're always afraid of some kind of
back rank checkmate you know there'll be
a rook check the queen will get on this
diagonal and you need squares you don't
want to get suffocate h5 is always a
good move for the defender to get in
uh because not only do you give your
king two squares g7 and h7 squares
thanks to the lift of the h-pawn but
also
especially after the move f4 has been
played
this kind of counter play this creeping
counter play with h4
really is annoying for the first player
the first player just wants the other
guy to you know be in a defensive mode
you can't pick up the rook
uh because of check
let's say king h7 you take this rook
well i've got at least a perpetual and
thanks to the
upon being on an age four uh just you
know give yourself uh yeah
credit so i was a
very surprised stunned in fact by the
move f4 and equally surprised you don't
get h5 but queen back and uh maurice
with some comments
well a repetition repetitions breaking
out everywhere it looks like
rook to g7 was played by anand rook to
b5 instantly played and then rooked back
to d7 by ananda rook to b2 and it looks
like they have drawn and you see them
pleasantly chatting as nothing much in
that position to play for they decided
nowhere to go no need to
bother themselves on this day
all right so uh a number of games ending
early
not the fighting spirit that we saw in
round one
and uh well again we're just kind of
stuck with the mdl game for for now our
excitement yeah and it seems like corona
okay he still has to figure out a couple
of things he's pretty low on the clock
but if you see the move counter he's
very close to mu 40 anyway so it doesn't
really matter it seems like hikaru
nakamura
this game and we have to take with the
queen but
uh oh and then came knight
knight f4 i didn't like that move can i
click on c4 precisely because when i'm
sitting there looking at white's king
uh being
quite vulnerable you'll want to get the
queens off the border and i'll allow
that the two bishops but you're gonna be
facing monster central knights very soon
well hold on is there a trick uh rook
takes a queen takes c4 there's a tree
you got it oh
oh that tricky hikaru nakamura look at
that he's got this i got that
i know i mean
he's got the cheaper potential doesn't
he i mean this is almost a position that
makes you want to think about a queen
sacrifice unfortunately you're an
exchange downstairs
sacrifice two two minor pieces again the
vulnerability of the what i was about to
say was the vulnerability of white's
king
almost leads me to wanting to play
the position with my bishop on c6 you
know on a very good day i get to go
knight d4 knight takes f3 yes sir not
going to happen you suggested earlier to
sacrifice a pawn now yeah yeah
okay you wake me up at six o'clock in
the morning i'll start sacrificing uh
the whole box full of uh pieces uh so
knight f4
you probably should take on d1
unfortunately but even so
i don't think that hikaru's
choice was uh preferable yeah was
i like taking off the knights actually
yeah
i think the knight on f4 is just
restricting the bishop on c1 because i
want to play bishop f4 oh without
question your bishop is in fact hasn't
moved the whole game you know you got to
get the guys
off the bench and bring him uh into play
uh no i i prefer us black to have the
knights on f6 and f4 then have them off
the board right and to be precise what
we were talking about
was that we had anticipated queen takes
d5 knight takes d5 knight f4
with the double attack against the
bishop as well as the knight if there
was a trade this comes with a tempo and
again the open d as well as the open e
files means that white has
some compensation yeah well
good play with the rooks let's put it
that way so we think there's been a
little bit of a hiccup maybe by both
players
the rook sacrifice as spectacular as it
was was a little unnecessary and now
hikaru's move knight f4 has given black
more chances to keep the pieces on the
board
king well and from london we have uh
jennifer shahadi with
vishy anand
thanks guys i'm here with vichyanand and
today's game what do you have to say
about it
well um we went for a kind of unusual uh
regards in setup
uh in fact it needn't have become one
because this classical d5 c4
structure that you aim for
wasn't self-evident in the beginning but
in the end i got it anyway
um
to be honest somewhere around the stage
where i play head 6 i wasn't very happy
with my play
i thought that i'm going to get a bad
version of aragosan and be slightly
worse
um
but i think i defended quite well after
that i mean i managed to rotate my
knight to e4 e4 and d6 that was crucial
because once this knight comes to d6
it's a monster defensive piece
and it takes a lot of the pressure off
black
if you miss something it it's
it's quite hidden it's not obvious
um
i don't think i was ever anything more
than symbolically
uh
i mean if three or four things that
happened i could have been better but i
didn't come close
so today at the london chess classic
it's a weekend so we have a lot of kids
who are watching your games a lot of
fans
what do you say to those kids a lot of
people ask well what book or what videos
should they watch
shall i say my books and my videos
i would say the main thing is
get something simple don't
just get something simple to grasp easy
to try out on your own and try to play
as much as possible that's the only way
you pick up these things
don't drown and stuff
so you mean when you say simple you're
referring to openings
not only i mean also simple games
simple concepts it doesn't have to
explain every last thing but
it should be something that you can
grasp quickly and try out on your own
because unless you try something out you
don't grow so from these players in the
grand test tour whose games do you feel
like have that sense of simplicity that
is good for kids to study
i would even say look at classical i
mean
games from um 1500 years back because
then um
people tried to implement plans very uh
slowly it seemed a more relaxed time i
mean nowadays the games are so complex
and if you analyze it with a computer
you can get lost very fast
um
i would say you know pick some classics
try and understand that slowly and later
on you can get into the complexity once
you grasp the basic idea great thank you
very much
so london chess classic uh study your
classics
solid advice
your classics indeed yeah i was uh
following the analysis of uh
vishy in the interview
and uh i just wanted to point out a
possibility here in the game where i
thought something interesting might
suddenly erupt
uh vishy didn't mention it
let me interrupt you sorry guys
we have levon actually oh please yeah
with jennifer in london all righty then
hey guys i'm here with levon aronian and
i am going to ask you same thing i asked
fishy did you agree with what he said
about studying the classics for the kids
here
of course that's what i did and that's
i think
we all should do
even
at the
age that i am i still
do
to
study the games of
the old masters are you running out of
games
no there's a lot that we don't know yet
now what about today's game were you
happy with how it went
no
i thought uh
i kind of liked my position but then
i've played this ridiculous rookie one
it's actually an oversight the fact is i
was planning to meet bishop f5 with
bishop takes a five knight five queen b5
but there i have missed that he can play
26 coin b7
rook fba 27 and 96 and the position
becomes double aged
yeah so
after that i i had to
play uh
normal moves to equalize so
from a slightly better position to go
into a position where you have to play
precisely to equalize
doesn't feel right and um today
um what would you say to
what do you feel about the atmosphere
today now with all the the kids here and
everything
yeah it's great
i i mean
you see so many people uh coming to play
chess and
uh it's it's always a joy to see the new
generation coming after you that will be
uh in the game
malcolm in his intro today to you said
referenced an article about or a show
rather about the armenia being the
cleverest nation in the world what's
that all about
yeah once
the bbc came to armenia and
because we were so successful in chess
so they interviewed me and
some other guys so that's what it's all
about got it okay so the cleverest is
the best chess player
yeah you know the chess player with
chess we measured the intelligence so
you understand really you haven't met
any dumb chess players
i'm kidding
all right thank you levon good luck and
part of your games thanks
back to you guys
thank you jennifer
lavonne a very very sweet guy
yeah and uh when he was talking about
the young generation of players and it's
nice
uh one of the things that i really
really admire the players for was when
they were here in saint louis we do have
a very large scholastics initiative
ourselves here in saint louis a lot of
children come from schools and they get
their chess boards out and they ask the
grand masters to sign and we have a
special day that we set aside a special
period of time for several hours that
the players are all signing the boards
and we get some really really great uh
photos of all of the kids and the smiles
as they're showing their parents look at
look at the signature i got mom
no it's always nice to have that
interaction with the players guys
absolutely
and
i can't think of any uh
anywhere else in the world that i have
seen that uh to such a degree as i saw
it when during the soviet times
uh i would go to these uh tournaments in
their playing halls
and just
massively packed i mean just think of a
tokyo subway type of uh packing of
bodies up against a wall where the
players were you know asked to sign uh
memorabilia and stuff and that those
were extraordinary times
we have uh
what do you my overall impression is
still uh hikaru
um
is in difficulties he solved some things
but
the fact that black has actually kept
this knight
on the board is actually in his favor i
think as you were saying and i
completely agree with this knight on
f4 is actually a bum steer it's a it's
in the wrong place it it prevents the
hikaru from developing his bishop
and really uh black's play is
straightforward he wants to put his
knight on d4 going after this f3 pawn
and you never never want to allow the
bishop to come onto this long diagonal
when suddenly it's not just winning
material it's creating
uh
checkmate light threats so
uh
white still has a number of problems
that he has to solve
bishop e3 to try to solve them and it
seems like maurice has some insight out
there this move
well the engines don't like bishop e3 at
all they felt like what you said yes
bishop on this long diagonal is going to
be a beast after all that's the bishop
he has and the two pawns of course for
the rook that he sacrificed so that's
what you have to understand in chess is
it's all about imbalances when you trade
bishop takes knight that imbalance
definitely decides how you should start
to play the game or at least suggest the
direction you should go in the imbalance
here is white has a rook so if the rook
starts to get busy on open files then
that's going to be compensation however
if the bishop
there's nobody to compete with it in
fact starts to do its own thing then
that's going to be a problem so here the
engine.knight e5
definitely must be played here stopping
this bishop from taking up a perch on
the c6 square instead he played bishop
to e3 so now the engine's like well wait
a minute what if i just played bishop to
c6 attacking this pawn and king g2 looks
like a natural defensive move by the way
bishop c6 was played now you play king
g2 and this is the key move to find
pawns under attack do you defend it no
no no no you're not trying to get
into some kind of equalish end game or
you don't want to bring your pieces
backwards you play the move knight to d4
a power move attacking with defending
and attacking at the same time the f3
pawn is again under fire now take a look
at what happens after this capture if
you try to take one of the pawns back
well knight to h5 a nice little
discovery hitting the rook paying
attention to this night the rook has
nowhere to go to guard the night as a
matter of fact so you can't just give
your knight away turns out you have to
give back the exchange and after a trade
on this square followed by this trade
and then the move rook to d8
black is up a pawn has a fantastic
bishop on the lawn diagonal all of
white's pawns are horrible this is
starting to shape up like a terrible end
game for
white and this is not what nakamura
wanted to see coming into the game
especially after his disaster from
yesterday well mini disaster he should
have won
a game against grishtrook now this one
it looks like he's going to get ground
down in a brutal end game and mvl
looking like a star
so higher went ahead and after bishop c6
played king g2 but i was actually
wondering yeah before that what was
wrong with knight e5 i'm assuming
there's some kind of tactical refutation
yeah i was thinking of the same thing
too my initial reaction was
oh i really want to play knight g4 right
yeah
i mean i'm a genius you take ig4 i take
on f3 with check and i pick up yet
another pawn uh but unfortunately knight
g4 knight takes and just while i'm
reaching to capture your bishop and
capture your rook i suddenly notice my
record the v8 is hanging yeah so and if
i if i recapture i've lost
my knight okay so the
uh
i was assuming rookie eight is probably
the move precisely
i was thinking the same thing as well
so that after nights
yeah
you know taking advantage of the
uh uncovered pieces knight takes c6 rook
takes e3 rook d8 check i just i block
with the bishop
knight is hanging on
um
pardon me on c6 and the pawn is hanging
onto f3 i think knight e5 rookie was the
but knight g4 you know
uh it's a kind of a blitzer's move if
you will but okay he played king g2 and
now mvl apparently has to find the move
knight d4 which is initiative which is
not a difficult move at all
because i mean how else do you defend
the precisely not only how else do you
define
with this knight on b5 as good as it
stands it wants to come to d4
and forces the bishop off the board
tactically speaking it's very easy for
even a
normal chess player to calculate that
you cannot take on d4 right and if you
try to go knight e5 now with that knight
on d4 you've got these seem very
yeah
yeah these
common forks with knight c2 so
with this bishop and knight both bearing
down
maurice had mentioned takes takes
this guy's taboo rook takes d4 knight h5
uh that's all she wrote uh
i got i
gotta go 95 i mean that bishop
yeah it's got to go i mean that bishop
would scare me to death but
unfortunately i mean
i must have some resources here well
even one of the things one of the
resources you have you you may not even
be afraid of the night take c6
v2 check is always coming down right so
you might even just i don't know
well knight d5 no knight
h5 um
with you know i got this
i got this ambush
uh that knight is going to be stuck on
h5 you have to play knight d3 i think
right exactly so the knight would come
back to d3 now you could put your bishop
you can maintain the bishop uh
well wait a minute there's no there's
not rook a4
i was hoping to go
but there's a bishop b3
uh two bishops yeah
definitely better for black and worries
just wanted to point out a line there
that you're going to like as for sure
here it comes knight to e5 bishop to b5
just keeping the bishop saying i dare
you double dare you to play rook takes
d4 and here it comes
knight to g4 this time without the
bishop on the long diagonal of course
like you said ambush on this night
if it can't move away because the
capture on this square and if you just
take this piece i mean it's being
attacked twice this night if you take
here then the bishops just erupt and
they look so gorgeous along these long
diagonals and what can you do if you try
to hold on to everything guarding the
b-pawn guarding the knight as well then
suddenly rook to d8 and we know about
these killer bees they're just looking
ridiculously powerful we're coming down
to d2 that's pretty much unstoppable in
the position and black's just going to
rank wide over the coals here this one
is tremendous so bishop to b5 that looks
like a normal natural line to happen in
this position remember he had to give
back a upon those so he's going to be
down the extra pawn he was he was two
pawns up still has one pawn but the
strength of bishops combined with the
rook
that kind of activity with an exposed
king and just weaknesses everywhere to
go after definitely gives black the edge
and we have a move by maxine bashir
graph he played rookie instead of knight
d4 and almost instantly hikaru decided
to react with
king f2
wow
c5
i'm assuming there's a reason let us
have a look
uh rookie 8 he was prepared to play
instantly
king f2 instead of the
greedy greedy thank you looking for the
right word uh bishop takes c5 was he
afraid of bishop h6 well maybe even g5
right away okay very good i'm thinking
that obviously i want to bring my rook
to e2 the knight stands in the way i was
going to
either play the move bishop h6 you
mentioned g5
probably simply if he's looking at this
bishop and i tell you
every human player who's ever stared
down a bishop like that wants to get off
that diagonal yeah and probably g5
knight moves g4 is coming hikaru wanted
no part of this no part of this okay so
that was why he played king f2 in an
instant and then it kind of makes sense
your rook on was on b8 you got it to a
a square with a tempo it's improved but
at the same time what did what have we
lost by
including the move rookie a king f2 and
knight g well the king on g2 well less
vulnerable less vulnerable and more
vulnerable at the same time because if
you ever played rook takes d4 i always
have knight g4 check so this thank you
so it's just very well yeah to point
that out what you have just said
uh with the rook on d4 pardon me with
the king on f2
there's this knight g4 check to the king
you take the knight and suddenly the
king is actually
quite vulnerable on f2 as well oops that
capture comes with a check
so
okay
and i like the rook on e8 because it
protects the e5 square the biggest
downside is that in positions where you
are down the exchange if you have
compensation whether it be one pawn and
you're defending or two pawns and you're
attacking that almost never that matters
you always want to keep your rook
exactly you always want to keep your
rook against the two rooks of your
opponent it's almost always a good idea
to keep your rook so the disadvantage of
having the rook on e8 is that suddenly
black has to be worried that white
challenges the e-file at some point and
again because of the very basic ways of
the way the chess pieces work you
usually don't want to discoordinate your
minor pieces by trading off one set of
rooks so in other words black will have
to move his rook away and thereby lose
the temperature
on the other hand
massive bond on d4
it's still looking very good for mvl
again this move knight d4
with this threat of knight c2 you don't
want to see this bishop we've always
yes you have to take on d4 i think right
and this just looks uh pardon me this
looks like after rook
the
rookie 8 rook d8 but he didn't do that
he went for
whoa
after king f2 that was the position we
left what has
uh mvl decided upon he said he just
wanted to go g5
a move that you pointed out a moment ago
but in a different position but maybe
this is a really good move because
look yeah well it's a tempo against the
knight let's say the knight goes to
i'm just throwing out a square
you want to
open up
the position as the king against the
king i mean this is
a nightmare right that's the
well let's put the knight on a better
square because that's what i'm afraid of
because the knight wants to go to t3 in
order to be able to go to e5 i don't
think okay so the knight wants to go to
d3 as you mentioned in order to go to e5
so let me
continue
okay and i'll continue
abc oh no no
c6 right
yes just a second uh knight g this night
then bishop has defended on
e3 by the night
so it's actually 94 doesn't win a piece
that's a pity of course
uh
knight g4 does not win a piece because
after king takes knight takes
knight takes okay i
um
i don't think this is as good
yeah this doesn't look good doesn't seem
convincing suitable
maybe g5 was just simply miss time
um
okay just a second let me try it again
let's do it again uh i'll try
uh i'm channeling mvl uh g4 which night
we went this night how about this check
takes
and i don't like giving up this
wonderful bishop of course
but how is this uh first instinct is
not favorable no i don't like this at
all but there's a weakness on e4 that
suddenly appeared yeah okay
a move or two just see if all right i'll
take on e5 yeah you dog you took my good
bishop i have to recapture and i guess
i'll go ahead and check you just because
i can
this is a check give a check yeah that's
not a case of the password
it sees a check of a check but
there's some weaknesses but rick jiwon i
don't know i i i have the feeling that
black
is allowing quite a lot of activity
well
i'm
i'm not
100 sure myself
now we actually have a draw
we have another draw it seems like
magnus carlsen and fabiano carona also
kind of expectedly oh for a long time of
course after we saw that move f4 yeah
and it seems like we have a perpetual
check on
that's what i was saying that f4
would always leave you vulnerable right
to a perpetual check and the players
have uh
yeah yeah that's the draw agreed right
there let's see how that occurred we
left it at these parts queen c5 b5 takes
a nice little calculation there right
and 23 checks yes that's very easy to
calculate perpetual
uh very thematic uh perpetual
um again not a very impressive game by
the world champion
coroner had no problems holding the draw
today exactly at all
yeah yeah
maurice what can you say about our games
today
well so far not a very exciting day to
be sure we've had all those draws it
looks like the players are playing
somewhat cagely and we can't say
anything about magnus he doesn't have a
candidates to worry about and i'm sure
he's not trying to hold back any
preparation for some world championship
match 10 months from now or what
whatever it is so clearly he's just not
quite in that amazing form that we are
used to and his rating continues to drop
ever so slightly with every one of these
draws as he comes closer to the field
although admittedly the field themselves
seem to be backing away from him too no
one over 2 800 with topolov's loss
yesterday no one in the world except
magnus right now sitting over 2 800.
this game
mvl is playing with fire and desire to
be sure let me interrupt you before we
go into that since we have magnus
carlson with jennifer shahadi in london
thanks guys i'm here with world champion
magnus carlson tell us today um at what
point did you think you had the best
chance for an advantage well i tried a
bit of a small ball
approach today
i felt that i was a little bit better
perhaps
than yeah i sacrificed the pawn but i
felt that uh
i wasn't really risking anything so
he uh well he didn't take the pawn um
he got a
kind of defensive setup then
try to change his um
chase his queen away from the central
position otherwise i couldn't do
anything but my king was just to work
and yes and at what point did you feel
like you had no more chances to win
um well already when you got queen e5 i
thought there was not much to do
so today is a special day the london
chess classic first weekend day lots of
kids um what kind of message or advice
do you have to the kids what types of
things should they be studying
uh well
keep more pieces on the board than i did
today
all right thank you very much world
champion magnus carlson back to you guys
in the studio
seemed a bit disappointed off putting
you know you're the world champion
you're the best player in the world you
have the white pieces against a key
rival a future rival not
not just a rival today but a future
rival for years to come
you want to
cement that yeah you want to plant your
authority you want to rubber stamp who i
am who you are and speaking of fabiano
we have him over with jennifer shahadi
i'm here with fabiano caruana who just
drew magnus carlton can you tell us a
little bit about
the opening um were you expecting this
how did it rank in your expectations no
i didn't really expect this it it's a
little bit better for white but it's i
think it's pretty harmless
and um
i mean i probably caused more
difficulties for myself than i needed to
going for um this queen b6 and a6
although it's probably objectively a
draw the entire time so you think you
could have just played something solid
like queen d6 instead yeah i mean i'll
have to suffer a bit but it's going to
be a draw
that it's you went for the more tactical
route i wanted to force things but i
kind of underestimated the strength of
the default so when somebody plays
something that's not expected that you
think is harmless are you happy because
it's harmless or disappointed because
you're not as like sharp on the lines
i did promise someone i would win today
so there was no chances for that after
about
10 moves
but
i can't say i was disappointed or
anything because
i mean
you know i could also because serious
problems in the opening and this was
was a relatively um
i mean relatively simple way to make a
draw
so you promised to win with black
yeah it maybe wasn't the wisest promise
to make
what are you going to do tomorrow do you
have any promises for us tomorrow
uh no no promises we'll see how it goes
all right thank you fabiano carona he's
got two dolls now in the london chess
classic and as always a little bit of st
louis here
thank you jennifer that's all order i
mean yeah
i'm going to beat carlson with black
yeah i promise it i promise well for the
children especially don't make promises
you can't keep
well it still draws a good result for
fabiano he'll be happy starting with two
draws sure yeah and maurice you were in
mid-thought when we had those interviews
yes well i forgot what i was talking
about
something more interesting uh speaking
of which promises you don't that's
certainly not something you do i
remember my good friend grandmaster
patrick wolf back in the day we were
actually playing against each other in a
big tournament in new york and he
promised someone that he'd be done with
the game after beating me really quickly
and be able to go out to lunch turns out
that i was hunting him down and missed
the win in the game and he ended up
getting a draw and afterwards he said
that's what he admitted to yeah you know
i thought the game would be over kind of
quick i was like dude you're my friend
talk about me like that i should have
beat you this game at any rate no
promises before the game you got to go
in a game with a clear head
this position
mvl definitely allowed too much here he
made it murky when he had really good
chances to just keep the position solid
knight d4 that's the money move he
should have played it as we said that
would have kept all uh his initiative
everything under control everything
balanced all his major advantages but he
did not find this move and instead he
played this funkier move g5 and this one
is now just setting the game into just
really murky waters it is not at all
clear that he's going to get great
chances here knight d3 g4 this move
knight d to e5 is the key move and why
now nakamura you know he's he's feeling
it he's feeling the surge in the
position white actually has order in his
position
centralized knight attack on the pawn
he's hitting the bishop the bishop did
go to d5 and it's this position we're
looking at and it turns out that white
has different choices the white's still
worse according to the engines but white
can play a move like rook to g1 here get
some energy along this line i believe i
saw a move rook to d3 as well is
actually quite interesting if you were
to grab this pawn off the board to move
rook to g1 now and white keeps
increasing his rooks that's what his dis
his disadvantage might be the bishops
but his advantage of the rooks and if he
can make them work and curtail black's
energy you see of course this rook under
pressure i mean this bishop under
pressure this bishop under pressure both
rooks trying to do work so
to murky right now he mixed it up a
little bit and you know hikaru he plays
chess 960 with the best of them so to
have a murky position where the pieces
look kind of weird that's just when he
gets comfortable well rochu1 was played
on the board so it seems like after g5
g5 g4 or rook g1 immediately bishop d5
oh pardon me
yes bishop d5 rook g1 and you know the
contrast between this position where
you know white's knights on c4 e5 look
good um
you know okay the material imbalance at
least the rook rooks are working
contrasting that to the moment when
black had just played the move knight b5
and white's trying to figure out what do
i do with my visas where did they go
it's definitely huge
even though i prefer black
no i also prefer black but it's not as
much as we used to
let's take a look at the standings
currently after we have four results so
far still pending on the nakamura
vasherla graph game we have four draws
all right today it seems like everybody
increased their score by half point and
well it all comes down to the nakamura
and the all game to see if we'll have a
decisive result
on today's games
and with that we'll take a short
commercial break and we will be right
back
mmm
mm-hmm
food
foreign
do
uh
so
come on
welcome back we're here on round two of
the london chess classic the last
tournament of the grand chess tour and
we only have one game remaining over at
the olympia conference center in london
england as hikaru nakamura seems to be
suffering in his game against vashiela
graf
after starting off with a dubious
opening to be kind i think yeah to be
kind to be kind but a big development
alejandro check it out
after the move rook g1
uh what hikaru was hoping is that he's
going to use this g-file to pressure
black's king
in response came h5 and suddenly h3 and
this
looks to be an egregious error as we
were on break
i was saying
uh oh this is great for black
and you cleared my cobwebs
after h3 clearly hikaru is hoping to use
the file but it could rebound against
him
after g4 takes f3 bishop h6
looks great check that out rook on g1
bishop on h6
oopsy daisy
knight g4 check
h takes g4 bishop takes h6
and suddenly this pawn on f3 this knight
is coming to d4
and it's black uh
it's got a really nice initiative going
here you just move the king out of the
way you can't
you can't allow this rook
to come into the game to e2 f6 is a huge
threat big time threat
and
suddenly hikaru uh
could be thrown backwards so
as a slight
well not a slight but perhaps a major
miscalculation
with the movement h3 the complicated
lines here come after knight g4 and i
think maurice can show us more of what
the computer is thinking in this
position all right
yeah actually that move you guys just
showed the variation is not that bad for
white there's something else that is far
worse actually
just going down this line after g takes
f3 bishop to h6 knight g4 check h takes
bishop to hg takes king h7 as you
mentioned
apparently the move rook a to e1 semi
organizes the black forces the white
forces excuse me f6 looks like a great
move but suddenly this into mezzo knight
to b6 changes the story quite
dramatically
the main move here believe it or not is
much more spectacular take a look at
this knight to e4 check instead of
knight g4 94 check and now of course
you're not going to take on on f3 with
the king and allow a discovery that
would be dangerous but king to e3 now
thinking everything's fine what are you
going to do about your g7 bishop well
how about giving it away
whoa yeah what
what is right this is crazy chess right
now this move simply is horrible rook
takes check king takes and this position
is just bad for for for white this rook
looks terrible in the position don't
move your rook over here you're not
threatening anything serious f2 could
come so that's a big problem for you
the key move and he has not played g
takes f3 by the way but the key move
after a knight e4 check and king h7
following this line bishop takes g7
looks like all right i just stole a
piece and suddenly f6
having lost the piece black plays like
it's normal like no big deal f6
attacking this knight going after this
one and about to take advantage of this
pawn going to f2 for example knight
takes f3 he's going to just take
and look at the organization of black's
pieces everything harmonious and
suddenly this king looking like it's in
a mating and of course his bishop is
also trapped inside of black's position
so this bishop is going down this
position is completely winning
for black according to the engine this
is over also knight d six nine at five
are threats this the king is actually in
a mating net so the knight appears on f5
well he's not quite mated so maybe it's
d5 the value is on d5 it's mate on the
board so black is the one in complete
dominance here turns out
mvl did not see this opportunity and
instead of taking on f3 going back to
this position he instantly played bishop
takes
c4
and the engine's saying he's still a
little bit better here after knight
takes
and knight to d5
but
now
more analysis seems to be showing that
actually the position is going triple
zeroes by the engines which is kind of
curious given the tension here in this
position and the aggression here they're
giving the move rook to e1 as equal
equal equal
crazy turn of events we're gonna have to
dig deeper guys in to see exactly what
these variations hold
wow i'm sorry like that was not gonna
the happen perspective it's so
counter-intuitive
after it takes
uh to play bishop h6 knight g4 every
human player would say okay you're
focusing your white is focusing on that
bishop on g7 i don't want to lose it
94 check yes you definitely consider the
move only because you instantly reject
king takes f3 because you've got this
knight
discovered
double check pardon me to the white king
and you get to pick up this bishop on h6
but then you go king e3
uh
okay even if you were to consider the
move king h7 and you would consider the
move
you don't say oh yeah beautiful
follow-up six that's that's three no i
mean you did you stop you just stop
yourself
and it's an extraordinary uh variation
is he car okay after what he did he took
on g4 i just want to okay let's uh i
just wanted to see yeah let let's bring
it whoa
lots of uh developments in the game
uh so h3 took on
on g4
take down e3 takes bishop takes b2 i was
kind of thinking bishop b4 first but i
don't know if he had enough time to
actually create a threat
well no
bishop is better
clearly by taking this pawn on b2
you've given yourself a square so let's
just say
if you go rookie once and you can always
take on h5 with check but i think
black's going to be okay with that right
and you know you you that this knight is
uh determined to get into the game with
a temple with a tempo i meant to say
like this so this is and
when we walk we can toss in g takes h5
king h7 that looks pretty ugly for white
it does
but it's also well i mean is it so
convincing
let's say for ex for argument's sake i
get out of uh knight c3 yes knight c3
and i drop with my rook back keeping the
knight protected and the problem is what
to play in this position right as this
knight is ready to to hop away
either to the f5 or g4 square and fight
for white
better
fine
is what the integers are saying going
again triple zeros in all these lines
saying the position has now stabilized
itself envio played quickly and the main
reason why maybe his time he had only 12
minutes and also maybe hikaru's time he
had only seven minutes and i think mvl
played in ikaru's time pressure a bit
too much and this is a mistake you can
often make and he just played very fast
but that said
the road to advantage was not easy he
had already blown it with g5 blown in
his very strong term but in terms of
being able to control the position
again we play human moves the computer
may have shown that crazy variation i
pointed out but most humans are not
going to study that line and at the end
like you said f6 just too bizarre to
look at positions like that and make
them seem reasonable but by playing very
aggressively with the move g5 he gets
into a position where you got to play
careful to control the action knight d4
was that money move from a long time ago
no question about it we see it before he
played g5
where did this happen back here even
rookie 8 wasn't necessary but when he
did get it in king f2 was imprecise
again knight d4 again and again
keeping the control over the position
blunting the effect of this bishop and
not giving white any chances whatsoever
to get that great play he got in the
game or at least some kind of crazy play
by playing g5 you're ready to create
that imbalance that white starts to say
okay bring it bring some more give me
some punches and now suddenly as we jump
to this position we see the effect of g5
and the rook suddenly has something to
do to chew on this rook has this file
this rook will find this file eventually
taking his no problem rook over and
because of this also the pawn on a5 and
the pawn on b7 that's a big deal in this
position because he can't just rush his
pawns down guess i'm just gonna throw
them down there and you have to suffer
because he can't create two past pawns
he that pin position you just mentioned
that we just saw you guys put up there
that
is a problem because you can't build on
it like i got the pin but i can't freeze
anything in this position and distract
him with pawns so
definitely a blown opportunity for mvl
and hikaru
yesterday he should have won today
probably should have lost so ah it all
worked out
wow well i couldn't agree with you more
maurice uh about that whole knight d4
versus g5 uh explanation the knight
really belonged on the square d4 having
said all of that
when you see this move bishop on d5
takes c4 automatically you start to
think okay right i'm giving up this
really really really great bishop for
these well-coordinated knights
and i've lost uh the edge that i have
been building up for some time yeah the
game is a little too simplified at the
moment exactly and again just to
continue the line that we had uh
kind of spied let's say there is a way
to risk a lot i think oh good no but the
way you were saying rookie one bishop c3
rookie two yes taking on a five might
just be a little too much
well
you know
three connected pass bonds you know
but unfortunately yes
yeah isn't it uh suddenly this lawn
might be it might have something to be
said yeah i've got some yeah suddenly
i'm a little scared a little bit scared
and with probably good reasons let's
just continue the line however
i don't like
maybe just put the bishop back
on the long diagonal again on a very
good day
those three past pawns are like
streaming
up the board
um
white has to be
still careful you think
yeah i do i do i mean these doubled h
pawns are
contained
the problem is i don't think
uh
i can
effectively
advance the pawns of the board without
giving this rook white has a lot of
material on the queen side since the
knight can always hop back the king is
very close the king on h7 is completely
cut off
yeah
but i need again
to generate threats on an open file i
think i want to use the e file if you
let me if you drop after for example
king
i
i want to try to
get some
active threats
going with rook e8 rook f8
yes
if white has actual counter play then
it's not so pleasant exactly
exactly
but yeah i think a missed opportunity
here for mvl yeah definitely had the
better of the position and it's true
that
yeah exactly what marie said after
nineteen knight on d4 yeah after 94 it's
possible that there was a variation
where he was better but
very very difficult to find i would
argue impossible to find for a human
well this whole bishop takes just
voluntarily dropping this bishop
so there we have it i let me just get an
update of the game and the current time
positions by the way
of the opponents they should be about
right uh they only have a few minutes to
make uh time control so yes
so the players by the way have been
following our analysis and maxine
decided to go bishop d4 as expected
hikaru is ready to play very quickly i
don't know what the role he's reaching
for his king and king f3 okay
okay
now it's sort of like you want to play
knight d4 check but your bishop's in the
way you can't make three and we've
probably looked at this position except
he hadn't they haven't played uh she
takes h5 check which is really something
hikaru can throw in whenever he feels
like it right
so we're anticipating rook on e2 to e1 a
little hesitation there
by hikaru but he did
eventually find the move now now what
yes exactly we've kind of uh
well we're happy that this pin
but okay i'm a little bit concerned that
this rook on e8 the knight on f5 is
threatening
um to move because the rook on e8 is not
protected
if i did something as mundane as rook e5
you can still play knight f5 right yeah
rookie five knight f5 i agree with you
completely how about knight
e4 now you can't move the knight because
the rook can be captured and there's no
rook takes e8 on your side i agree okay
so
because this knight g5 is an annoyance
you got to take right i would assume
it's just yeah yeah takes in king h7
so
on a good day
black can play knight d2
check and tie
you up
she's still unclear but yeah okay on a
good day knight d2 is a threat
yes um let's see what to play in this
position
right okay
so i could play rookie two maybe tips to
get out of it
well rookie too does that stop me from
playing knight d2 check i don't think i
have a problem with knight d2 i can just
take
if i take with the bishop then you can
counter pin me either with rookie two or
rookie one clear
and rook takes e3 check you don't i'm
not particularly afraid no with such a
reduced amount of material agreed so
after rook e2 92 is not a threat
but
was mentioning how important that a5
pawn is now
uh can't create anything on the king
side on the front side sorry
okay well i've got a pass bomb let's
push it
past paul some problems i mean
i have ripped g4
oh gosh i was going to meet that with a
nasty
move but i can't play
my intended knight d2 for the same
reasons as previously mentioned you just
take it
okay so i don't want to undermine
my own pieces
silly move silly
i was thinking gesture
but it just runs into a check so that
doesn't work
so king h7
um
hold on
ninety whose turn is it rookie two also
rook g2 i was thinking how about f5
i'm not exactly you can just take it
right
well isn't the rook on g1 hanging yeah
but i don't know oh i see what you're
saying
you give up
the
exchange
but you've got a great blockade well
even you ever have to be a little
careful yeah exactly i better take it i
better get that
quickly yeah exactly
i'm just thinking he's saying okay i
better do it uh
by playing something like this and maybe
v6 on my next move
okay maurice has some insights for us
here in this position as well
well one of the dangers of playing chess
that happens to all of us is what
happens when you have a better position
and suddenly you no longer have a better
position and mvl is precisely in that
situation everything about this game
said better better better nakamura
played the opening with these lost tempe
of claire benoni that was perfectly fine
for black then he got a chance to
sacrifice an exchange did mvl at one
point very aggressively taking on f3
when you do that in a game your
adrenaline definitely spikes you're
thinking this is me i'm going to take
you down and then all of a sudden some
inaccurate moves caused him to get a
position that was not advantageous as we
see there he has played the move knight
e4 and by playing the move g5 the game
is turned and turned enough now that he
no longer has any real advantage on the
clock in fact he's behind on the clock
and nakamura has no disadvantage no
worries whatsoever there and it's clear
that
the advantage is gone what do you do now
that your advantage has dissipated
of course us sitting on the side will
say well don't do anything crazy make
sure everything's fine
play simple chess but it's not so easy
when you had tasted this opportunity of
an advantage and you should you feel
like rightfully i should win this game
well here you see he doesn't have that
much to do so he's just playing
defensive moves maybe he's been forced
of course from the last move to play
this this situation but what about
hikaru is he starting to think okay i
was worse for so long but now maybe i'll
try to hunt you down if you give me the
right chance so switching the brain on
and off from worse to better to to equal
when you do all of that sometimes
players will make errors
these guys are experienced grand masters
from the best players on the entire
planet so don't expect them to make any
blunder psychologically right now and
it's not as though the position is
extraordinarily complicated but it is
clear one for sure one thing mvl blew
his great position and now
he has to be careful don't go under the
illusion that black is better anymore
because that ship has sailed
thank you maurice uh absolutely on the
button right i mean
when he played the move rook f3 you know
he was ready you know to pose for a
camera and say okay i played the
brilliancy of the round right uh
a dozen moves later
the vapor is vanished there's no
advantage
but you're still you've got that
history of uh the position and you're
still
uh chasing the victory that is no longer
there yeah and you end up getting
yourself into a real pickle
so
uh
it's so easy to
go wrong okay and they got this position
on the board and hikara played rook
cheese
which is something i was also
considering exactly um
very sensible
move you're getting out of this
pen i'm thinking that black should play
rook e6 yeah it seems like that move
would be okay but actually knight c2
might be an issue
knight c2 unless you can meet it with f5
because you don't have any of these
tricks with knight d2 chuck i understand
that you wanted to play that in case i
won knight f5 right exactly your knight
on c2
not only defends the rook it attacks the
bishop attacks the knight
f5 maybe and now
takes takes king f4
suddenly
the position has changed dramatically
this is the kind of stuff that we you
know i didn't want to see on the board
exactly exactly so
so
yeah it's it's gone wrong rookie 692 is
probably already better for white i
think maybe i have to go f6 to go knight
g5 check and bail out but h4 is a good
answer look at enough pieces defending
maybe just knight d6 i think
yes oh just make the pin actually a pin
and if you take on if you're gonna go
knight t2 yes maybe i can just trade off
the rooks and go knight c4
knight c4 bishop c3
knight c4 bishop c3
yeah knight again you want to get rid of
this i like knight c4 though because if
you're going to play rook a2 i'm not
really scared of anything no that is for
sure
um i don't think but for sure the crisis
is passed now for hikara yes no doubt
about it wow
um
big time turnaround again uh hikaru has
been on both sides uh with grishok and
mbl today yeah and actually both black
was uh having the upper hand which is
unusual yeah well let's take a quick
look at the schedule going forward into
the tournament just so you guys know
exactly when to tune in
so we already have a round tomorrow
remember that it is also earlier than on
the weekdays tomorrow we start at 8 00
a.m here in st louis 2 p.m
london time where players will be
playing every day
except for wednesday wednesday december
9th will be the player's rest day
i thought it was a
commentator's rest day
i think we'll be enjoying it as well
all right so our only game remaining of
round two
um
the advantage we've seen
the advantage that mvl had basically
from the opening
uh precipitously slip yeah and i don't
think he's worse but he definitely has
to be careful
well isn't that the definition of worse
though then you have to be careful i
think when you're worse you just i mean
one side actually has a clear way of
improving even
even against optimal play okay you know
the position remains unpleasant here i
think if a maximum finds a couple of
good moves he should be able to just
draw the game okay so you you reckon
that for example let's go
knight d6
um
do i have to do anything special i don't
have to move my rook right away well let
me break the pin for a sec
okay now
um out of curiosity this straight up end
game with three pawns
how do you do what do you mean straight
trade everything on e3 and take on
a5 at the end okay i follow you
completely take trade everything and
then
follow up with the fork yeah now the
knight's terrible i get it yes
three pawns are three pawns
yes the knight is a little bit uh stuck
for sure
i mean this still looks like it's very
likely to be a draw you might grab all
my pawns on the queen side the best size
island
h pawn i can play knight c6 for example
or even start with king h6
right and you mosey you yeah
i'm wiping you out over there you're
wiping me out over there
likely rook versus knight in a draw
which is a gotcha
so um
yeah yeah 96 looks like the move
agreed and by the way uh the clock times
once more because that is a factor not
anymore not anymore
uh they've made time control
yeah
so
we're gonna have to wait for the players
steven maxim actually fights a couple of
accurate moves he still has the
possibility of falling into hot water
certainly and definitely it's a higher
chance than hikaru doing anything wrong
it seems like it doesn't really matter
what hikaru does he'll be fine
one of the things that
i've been afflicted with uh throughout
my chest career is whenever i felt i
equalized for some reason it's like my
brain switched now that i've equalized
i'm better yes right right so i was
really motivated when my opponent let
their advantage to slip
because i'm thinking okay now my
opponent is feeling psychologically
downcast
i've got equality therefore i can press
will uh hikaru
be overly optimistic himself um
without worrying
i don't think he's going to be overly
optimistic because there's just not
enough on the board the problem is that
his pawns are quite static his pawn on
a5 is not really good uh his pawn on h i
mean probably he's a victim in fact upon
an a5 and the double pawns on the h file
there's just a little bit more
frothiness here to play for then it
would be nice but but what is he playing
for i mean it's even hard to figure out
what white is trying to do specifically
if some trades happen and he loses the
pawn how do you justify that it's your
h-pawns are you going to win the game
that if he loses the a pawn so i don't
think he's gonna overestimate this
position he's gonna look around and see
if the guy blunders that's about it and
the only thing that can happen is if mvl
starts to play some inaccurate moves and
allows the a-pawn to somehow stay on the
board but imagine he has to lose the b
pawn the b7 pawn and the a6 pawn in
order to make this eight pawn come to
life if the apon goes off the board it's
just not any real play so
i don't think he's going to overestimate
this position but i will say from mvl's
point of view he hasn't defeated
nakamura in a classical game right his
score is 3-0 for nakamura and nakamura
already was trying to make fabia
customer and over the board chess having
a very positive results against him and
he could have gotten the monkey off his
back by defeating
nakamura finally just to say yes now
that i've done it i'm going to start
doing it more often you get that first
blood and start to feel more confident
but
lately he's still only been able to draw
and he's he hasn't solved the nakamura
problem as yet of course he was a
younger player when he was getting
pummeled by the more experienced veteran
nakamura
but he still wants that win he's still
chasing that first victory and he almost
could have had it today
but
what do they call nakamura tricky tricky
resourceful
okay
knight d6 i'll tell you what i'm playing
for with white i'm trying to put my rook
on e7 i'll give you a heads up knight d6
rook on g2 to e2
big dreams knight g4 rookie seven
how do you go let's
let's see it um
all right well you got some tricks
definitely if you i trade everything
you're gonna go rookie seven at the end
that's the dream that's the dream all
right
i understand your dreams
all right i don't want to trade
everything but i don't know what to do
either well i was thinking that you
might be lured
into the move bishop c3
rook d1 knight
b5 eyeballing the d4 square
knight f5
and i was hoping for rook takes king
takes and again on a very good day
this is what i'm trying to do for hikaru
to swing the game solidly in his favor
unfortunately i think after knight d4
checked this probably still is just a
draw
are we so certain yes because i think
with the sea pawn
uh you take with the c pawn i'll
greedily grab it
grab us as much as you're going to give
up both the
yeah i don't think that's much of an
issue because i take on
h5 i don't think you have any real
winning chances so just to just to put
some moves on the board for a second
you're thinking that
even if i
both take both yeah wow
i still think this is a draw
you don't have to take on h5 actually
but
just to show what you think even this
with so long as this d4 pawn remains on
the board
right yeah importantly the pawn on h3
is
winning in most scenarios because it's a
wrong colored bishop
i think
but
and it's also below the fifth rank which
is important in certain right so you're
saying rook and h-pawn against bishop
against the wrong-colored bishop should
win unless the pawn is on h7 or he
then you got the draw but here because
you've even got a d-pawn you can't go
with your king and right you got to keep
an eye on the d-pawn it's uh it's hard
so okay well um i mean obviously this is
not the cleanest
and for mvl quite a bit no he's not
gonna go into this it's quite quite a
sad yeah but yeah i'm saying that even
in worst case scenario yeah pretty
drawish maurice
that's the problem this a pawn if it
drops off the board
then you're left with these wretched h
pawns and any trades just lead to easy
quality for black but it turns out even
in that line you guys mentioned this
rook e2 and you try to get some some
stuff going trying to land a punch he
has unfortunately black actually has a
very direct move rookie five look at the
unit of these four pieces looks very
attractive lots of harmony created and
attacking this pawn on h5 and saying
what do you have exactly what are you
trying to do if you can't improve your
pieces the move knight c2 runs into
simply rook takes h5 and if you want to
get rid of the strong bishop pawn takes
suddenly the pawn on a5 is going to drop
two and i think we'll all agree that
this is a quiet draw so rook's rook to
e5 would be the blow there there's
nothing else this position is now a draw
knight d6 was the key move though he
found the right move best move in this
moment right here knight to d6 very
accurate and
if ikaru plays just a couple of moves he
can look around i think he's going to
notice that he has no advantage
whatsoever and it's time for them to
stop the game i think he's going to look
no he'll try for sure look and see if
there's some kind of something in there
but
he's
probably gonna realize he's gonna
come up with nothing at all we mentioned
before but it's worth emphasizing
when you're playing with the extra
exchange
nine times out of ten it's
in your favor with the extra exchange to
trade the rook take the rook off the
board in and we saw a crystal clear
example of that
by what
line
the line maurice was showing that the
defenders rook suddenly become
became very good
on the fifth rank after rookie five so
i'll have to pull in my own horns there
a bit and say
yeah
i better play a move like knight c2 to
ensure that i get that rook off the
board and we were looking at some lines
that went like this
a while ago
with knight c4
that we were
reducing the game to uh an even
draw equality yeah and i still think
this looks pretty drawish it does
um
so wow so five draws if we're right in
our outcome of this game which we've
seen weirder things happen i mean but
still not that but nine draws out of the
uh two rounds again i i thought that i'm
okay with the four draws of the first
round because i really thought there was
some really tense thrilling uh battles
that
you know the players today i felt you
know like less so i mean uh yeah it
wasn't uh
the great uh energy
uh of the first round and by far the
biggest energy was concentrated on this
game yes still going on
but outside of this one i mean it felt
like a very lackluster round for sure
thank you that was a good word i was
looking for lackluster yeah
yeah
but uh i must say that uh malcolm payne
in round one when he was introducing the
players will mention that besides being
u.s champion uh hikaru is the defending
london classic
champion and that
malcolm mentioned very specifically that
hikaru is a very big favorite with the
british public because he brings it
and uh
you know for the first two rounds
his game
has really been capturing our attention
because of uh
uh
the quality
and the imbalance the assignment the
entertainment has brought to the board
has exactly
definitely it's been the highlight of
both rounds i think and so giri won
right yesterday i think everybody was
focused on hikaru's game exactly
yeah no definitely a crowd pleaser
hikaru nakamura still always with a
fighting spirit
and it seems like okay he's not going to
be able to take home the point if mvl
continues right
very well but you know hikaru is turning
it around and as we mentioned
psychologically sometimes it is
difficult to play a position where you
are better right and suddenly well
you're basically playing for equality
yeah so again that key move knight d6
has been played and
the very desirable
plan for white is to uh force the issue
and to trade
rooks with knight c2 but unfortunately
it's just simply not enough
right and again
just to mention
uh
if white does try to play games
that was me with my gamesmanship playing
the move rookie too this move rook e5
that i had underestimated
is very strong
i forgot that when the knight
came back
uh truthfully
that
i thought well i'll go king g4 this is
where i basically said oh isn't this
nice i'm going to get rook coming here i
forgot
that this rook
comes across the board and takes a key
pawn
for a win right yeah you know he
cuts my legs off there with that move
rook takes a4 a5
and uh no i don't like the fact that
there's a black rook in the position any
car did play rookie too but not this
route
i was like what really played rookie e2
rook e2
okay
yeah i have several options here as
black i'm assuming i can trade
everything off right that was the one
where you said that
uh bishop takes rook takes rook takes
king takes knight c4 check taking away
my apon we had a position like this
a moment ago and we agreed that
black's king
would uh end up capturing both h pawns
and the knight would come back and
white would wipe out the queen side yeah
it should be okay i mean white could be
more ambitious and maybe play something
like king e5 king f6 or instead of king
d5 but i mean it's hard to believe
i would be very reluctant to
allow black
the three connected past pawns
push you mentioned
unless there's some checkmating ideas
well i was hoping
oops that wasn't i was
get those doggies moving just a second
hold on where is it there it goes
uh b5 um
it looks dangerous and there will be
soon variations where white can no
longer bail out
not even with a perpetual check
yeah
no exactly that you don't do that and we
do have actually a new move anyway so
rookie 5 was played very similar to the
other variation except the rooks maybe
are not as clumsy both of them of them
being on the e file
maybe a slightly better version but
still not something terribly impressive
after knight c2 rook takes h5 was played
and in fact all of these moves were
played yeah okay and well seems like has
no problems
well definitely not i mean again we
haven't succeeded
in our rook trade the question is if
black is playing for anything
well why not
why not
i mean if a lot of white pawns fall
yeah
i also have some knight f5 ideas and
some positions exactly exactly the pawn
on h3 is hanging at the moment you
probably want to defend it
i don't know what would you play here
with white
what would i play here with light unless
uh hikaru has some very forcing
variation
yeah i was about to say unless he has
some very forcing kinds of counter play
with rook e8 you better take that bishop
and he did
the bishop
kind of as a standout right
okay and now we have a5 and h3 hanging
so i guess again you need some kind of
precise move
exactly
although to be fair any time that you
trade rooks it's just going to be okay
for black for white there's no way you
win if i manage to trade brooks yeah
this is me by uh again trying to sucker
you into
some trap i don't know if it traps the
right word i probably ended up doing it
to myself
but i'm hoping that with this rook on g4
and now that you've taken away the
h-pawn i'll just be able to
manage and checkmate you indeed uh
something of this kind of nature
so maybe you better
not greedily get your hand
in the cookie jar over here on h3 so
probably rook g4
rook d5 perhaps
oh richie for westblade so yes
trickster
yeah trying something well i was
thinking that if you played rook d5 i
wanted to play rook g2
uh with the knot with the knight with
the nuts so subtle
all these tricks with you yeah yeah
by the way uh that's an inside joke
with alejandro and myself we were
playing a blitz match together
uh i was complaining about your
resourcefulness and i was calling him
the djokovic of the chess world diseases
returning all my serves
at the chessboard it was a fun match
right now we've got to do that again
so okay we got uh rook g4 on the board
let's actually think about what nbl can
play which i'm assuming is pretty much
any move yeah you can go knight c4
knight c4 looks
intriguing yes uh there is a threat on
e5 i'm also taking on
a5
h3 will also be hanging at some point
well let me
capture capture capture capture
and uh
let's sneak down the board right rooks
belong on the seventh rank right well
this kind of becomes one of those
positions where if you're not mating me
you're not gonna win so i mean if i play
rook takes h3 i'm assuming i cannot
really play knight c6 i think well
recorded it not completely you can play
nine six i apologize because i thought
that uh you can defend the rook but i
have another the king g6 looks good yes
king g6 looks good and you have another
fork coming in i have to do it the other
way i apologize i have to put
d7
yes
not to get
hold on does knight c6 actually work
again because there's a knight d4 check
at the end no i got rook d7 so sorry no
no 95 anyway
jack team g6 and
two
forking squares
uh win an exchange back and a draw yeah
okay i like knight c4 if everything
works it's kind of hard to find all of
these nine moves right right right those
tricky night moves
yeah some sort of draw but i still think
that there should be something
easier
for for black i mean
rook g4 yeah
if i take on h3 you want to meet me
basically right so you're going to go
king g2 yes that is basic that's the
basic uh okay but also i think
retreating down the h file should be
something like rook h5 it's hard to
believe that black has
issues issues
okay
uh what can i do um you probably should
take the pawn
need i ask
take the pawn yes
uh rook takes
well now
knight f5 something like that rook d7
rook d7 something like knight h6 and
yeah now that i'm defended this is
completely dead yes agreed
there's no there's no hope here guys
this one is definitely drawn he just
doesn't have to blunder that's it stone
blunder and it doesn't look like one of
those types of positions you know we
talk about these five draws that will
happen today and and nakamura saying
that the players are not going after
each other in this tournament because of
the candidates the four players missing
from the candidates however including
magnus carlsen you got to think magnus
is happy if players are not aggressive
right now he'll get the double whammy
because he'll he'll not only have to
worry about
revealing any novelties because he
doesn't know who he's going to play
after the candidates but he'll win
london his rating keeps going down every
draw from magnus carlson is a small
minus it might be only a decimal point
point four here a point three there but
it adds up there was a time when magnus
carlsen was knocking on the door of 2900
we were wondering after he broke 2880
would he be a
2900 player the first in all of history
now he's
back knocking on 28 20s somewhere that
just sounds like he turned into a fish
like
what happened you're magnus carlsen of
course 20 28 20 is nothing to steal that
and sneeze that and uh from the drubbing
he put on me in our blitz match i won't
dare call him a fish
but he's not playing according to his
lofty absolutely lofty standards that
won him tournament after tournament
after tournament we were stacking up the
records just in the last few years and
now he's looking quite mortal so we'll
see whether or not he gets some
confidence from the fact that nobody
else seems to be running away with
anything right now geary contends with a
draw today and the rest of the players
only making draws so far so a lot of
tournament still to be played even to
paulov at the bottom of the tournament
table is still within fighting chances
of first
uh thank you maurice
i still have to say i'm
a big believer magnus i mean the last
five years
of what i've seen magnus do on on the
professional circuit has just simply
been phenomenal
miracle magnus comebacks haven't we seen
it all the time
i'm sure that magnus approached london
with the idea look i've got to reassert
myself
if i can win first i can win
the inaugural
championship yeah a grand chester
crown
i mean he made no
he made it very clear to the chess world
when he entered in berlin he wanted to
be the world
world classical champion the world rapid
champion the world blitz champion look
he wants to be the grand chester
champion as uh well you know so uh he he
he's going to come back in my opinion
that's part of the problem when you get
to the top how many mountains
do you get to climb how many more
mountains you of course you want to
dominate we look at the golden state
warriors for example in basketball you
know they won the title and people say
well you know maybe they were lucky they
didn't play all the best teams or the
best point guards from all those teams
and they come back the next year and
they say uh no we want more and they
even said steph curry who was the mvp
from last year may have improved his
game maybe the most improved player in
fact from last year which is incredible
that the guy who wins the mvp has that
kind of hunger passion desire to keep
going and proving i want to be better i
want to dominate that's extremely hard
to do you see it in rare people like a
michael jordan or tiger woods in his
prime that just want to get better even
if let's revamp my game
magnus has won so many tournaments it's
so clear that he was by far the best no
one challenging him no one even coming
close and now he's got to say so what
what am i supposed to do next when
another world title
well prove that i'm still the world
champion i got that i'm number one in
the world yeah you know got that which
tournament are you going to put in front
of me it's all these same tournaments
with guys i'm dominating well people are
now knocking on his door he's becoming a
bit older
25 wow he's not really old but people
already talking about oh maybe it was
fabi okay maybe it's wei yi out of china
eventually will be there so he needs
some kind of challenge to spur him on to
make him say okay that's it i'm putting
my foot down i'm going to show you
why i am the dominant player right now
of this generation and will be for years
to come and i think that's the
motivation issue we're facing with
magnus carlsen right now and maybe a
lack of it as he enters sort of the
middle part of his career
but winning never gets tired
it's always exciting to win and he's the
kind of player that gets
he's very upset with himself when he
loses and he's his biggest
critic as himself
he's had a losing streak i mean
it doesn't matter how you look at it the
fact that he's dropped 50 rating points
speaks for itself yeah it more than
speaks for itself it's something that
carlson really wants to prove that he's
able to go back to not only a position
where he is the number one player in the
world which he still is undisputably
it's the fact that he's a dominating
number one player in the world where
players were saying how much gap is
there between carlson and second place
and right now even though the gap still
exists yes it's not because carlson is
crushing everybody no it's like the
worst
sad you know everybody's kind of like
deflating a little bit yeah
i can't uh unless you were there by the
way it was really hard to capture it
you know in interviews in discussions
but i was in norway
in the norwegian television and the
chess fans of norway
they're such magnus carlson fans
and the level of his
disappointment at his own performance
that he had in norway you could just see
that this was tearing him apart that as
world champion he was so angry and
frustrated with himself not with his
opponents not with anything that anybody
had done to him or anything like that he
just wanted to win so badly in front of
his home crowd
i saw a very very motivated world
champion and i mean
he'll he'll come back he wants to win at
an event in norway sorry people like
magnus carlson they don't compete
against the players in their generation
they compete against history they are
going to be looked at years from now
he's going to be looked at years from
now as
was he as good as bobby fischer was he
as good as alakine was he as good as
capoblanca gary kasparov has there ever
been a time in gary casparo's career i
can't think of it when he just suddenly
shed rating points and had horrible
tournament after horrible tournament i
mean the guy just simply came in and
stomped everybody all the time
throughout his whole 10-year tenure from
like 85 to 95 before he started playing
the computer matches gary just simply
dominated as a young player
when he hit his 30s he was still the man
and who was he competing against he was
competing against fisher alekhine he's
putting records up that those guys you
have to look at perspective and of
course you can never say who the
greatest player is of all time that's
always going to be up for debate but you
will be putting his name in that that
argument and he can rightfully say yeah
you know when i don't have to say it you
guys can just see it from the numbers
i've put up magnus has definitely
already started to put up those kinds of
numbers those kind of records the number
of tournaments he won in a row or came
in typhoo first which have just been
incredible but it still hasn't gotten to
the mythic level as yet and he's working
on it but these kind of hiccups or this
setback that he's experiencing right now
uh he's better he better get out of it
or he's going to look like uh
maybe of a short-term champion i mean
this this one in norway when he just
made a horrific uh
mis mis step just ignorance from knowing
the time control and tripped up and lost
this first game this was the beginning
of an incredible slide that has
continued uh throughout after this
tournament and uh and beyond and this
year he lost a couple of horrible games
in the team championship it doesn't call
the game's horrible but but for him to
be losing uh so often is just not normal
so again he's not competing necessarily
from against these players he's already
proven that he's better than everyone
right now that's for sure but he's gotta
get in his mind nope i'm
one of the best in history that's what
i'm trying to prove maybe the best in
history if he broke 2 900 i think we'd
all be thinking whoa
what the heck and but to do that now
imagine what he's going to take from
magnus carlson from this moment to get
over 2 900. i mean he's going to have to
do one of those epic runs like he did
when he's when he got to the title that
he has now and not get into the melez of
just being a world champion
uh to echo some thoughts
uh one of the most extraordinary players
and for me the greatest chess player in
history is gary kasparov
his career started like a meteor a comet
burning across the heavens
and he really didn't have any setbacks
all the way up to becoming world
champion the biggest single setback that
gary kasparov had in his whole chess
career is this little asterisk he loses
a short match for world championship
match with vladimir kramnik
gary was humiliated he was super angry
after lose if he if there was a question
of gee gary what's your motivation
you've won every tournament in the world
linares tillberg blah blah blah todd of
steel three times running what's your
motivation well i tell you what it was
when he lost that world championship
match title to vladimir kramnik he went
out and just won every single event he
started playing it
and
maybe it's a weird kind of way
if magnus for whatever reason decided
well the fiji world championship wasn't
you know
going in a fashion that he
he wanted to defend his title or
something of that nature he would want
to prove himself number one by far oh
yes
but yes sir yes
gary won his first championship his
title in 1985 right that world
championship was two thousand years
that's 15 years i mean who dominates for
15 years
and it was domination there was no
question about it even when all those
young guns kramnik was in the argument
uh yvonne chook back then anand i mean
all those guys gelfand they were all
chasing him down and it would be who's
gonna be second
like he walks in okay who's second who's
second because you know this is over and
don't don't beat him he would lose one
game what would happen he'd pummel the
next six guys just crushed them game
after game that you just hadn't seen
such a tournament a champion he's world
champion for one but also just in
tournaments he was just so relentless
karpov used to win tournaments what plus
two plus three was like a miracle wow
gary was about plus sixes plus sevens
just overwhelm you and dominate the
players of his time so 15 years running
and then after he lost like you said he
just to keep that burning fire that
motivation he was already into his late
30s when he lost his match
i believe he was 37 or 38 years old
losing that match in 2000 so he must
have been 37 exactly these guys are
still playing but it looks like the draw
is almost inevitable again
can magnus in he's only 25 years old if
he doesn't even make it to 30 years old
and stay world champ then he's not going
to be put in that pantheon of the
greatest ever it will it will not be his
destiny's birthright to claim that even
though his rating is the highest rating
ever but with inflation and all that i
don't think that would be the argument
so magnus needs that motivation and he
needs to start winning some tournaments
yet again and prove that his time has
not faded the players have not figured
him out he's still the best clearly and
will continue to prove it so in the
years to come but right now he's
certainly in a bit of a crisis well i
mean he's still i think the strongest
player in history and i think that even
though he only reached 2880 once and
then he's dropped down i don't think
there's any doubt that he
is at any point the strongest player in
history i think just his history yes
i mean i think that it goes back to the
argument we were having before you can't
regeneration compare generation wise i
mean the fact that he reached 28.80 and
at that moment in time
it's he was just so dominant over
everybody else at that precise moment in
time i think he was just untouchable no
matter who you tell me in history now
that being said it is a far far away
from the legacy that for example
gary kasparov left off as you guys are
saying it's such a domination yeah and
ali kharpov i mean it's a different kind
of best and i think that magnus is
definitely not satisfied with having
that spur of brilliance that happened
one time you reach that really high goal
i think it's something he wants to keep
and it's definitely something that is
affecting his play right now because he
wants to see himself again where he was
when he reached 28.80 well you know
someone who this reminds me of although
it's completely different circumstances
is tiger woods i mean tiger woods was
such a dominant player could you even
imagine anybody playing as well as him
there was a point where even jack
nicholas who was one more matrix than
anyone said
the guy's gone past me that that's a
given i mean come on he look at how well
he plays he's incredible and it was just
again a point where tiger was just it
that's that that's clear we're waiting
for him to win 20 majors 25 majors 30
majors and then through his own personal
failings he was not able to fulfill his
destiny and now it looks like he will
never catch unless something dramatic
happens look like he'll never catch jack
nicholas and and then there's gonna be
that asters like yeah
sure he was the best ever come on do you
remember tiger back in the early 2000s
forget it i mean he was it was meteoric
but he hasn't won as many as jack and
there's always going to be that question
mark so i think it's a very similar of
course different circumstances and
there's a long way to go still from
agnes clearly but
the legacy that's a great word the
legacy of having uh put up
and and for such a long time that you
know kids are born and they become
teenagers in your reign
and not just a few years before they're
saying oh no he's not necessarily the
most dominant player it he had a
meteoric rise for a few years and
sustained it but you want generations to
remember yeah it's all about magnus
well again uh for me when i start
thinking about the world of chess and
how many great chess players they are in
the world of chess and under the
upcoming
candidates tournament as well i always
think about world champions and who made
it to the uh world championship right
and the idea that we there's so many
great players who never even got a
chance to be challenger where everybody
thinks of paul carras and akiba
rubenstein and many many many others
and
then you think to yourself well look at
vichy and nand okay we didn't mention
him as a dominant figure in the world of
chess but come on
five times the world champion five times
he won the world chess championship
title
and you think to yourself well wait a
minute it's just a great honor to have
qualified and made it as challenger to
win five world championship titles you
know you've got to tip your hat
and there's a lot of hat tipping going
around
at
the game that we have
the players more and more bonds coming
off the board i'm thinking
getting closer and closer to draw i'm
seeing this move rook a3 check i don't
know about yourself
that looks like the most logical just
going after this h pawn if you allow
black to take it well there's going to
be no issues
and i can even hit you with a check
downstairs
as well if you move your king yesterday
i can do anything exactly
so we really uh we think that this is
getting
more and more dead 41 minutes to 54
minutes so no time issues either yeah
and there's no reason to rush either
yeah mbl has
kind of a couple of options i mean he
does have to connect it past pawns
there's
a knight which is always tricky
and there's no reason not to at least
push the pawns a little bit before
agreeing to anything
also uh when you think uh world
champions and again um
uh vessel vessel and topolof
2006 he plays in uh
san luis
argentina
the best players in the world
uh double round robin
plus seven you know like dominating and
everybody said well
you know do you consider yourself gary
kasparov's equivalent or something like
that and
the vessel just laughed and said look
you know i did it once yeah you know i'm
a fraction one-eighth of gary you know
like he he really recognized that as
powerful as a performance that he gave
which was astonishing it really was
that you know it just is a fraction of
what gary had achieved so for me again
it's gary but i also yes
just to buttress your point
gary kasparov in 1986 became the number
one player in the world 1986.
19 years later in 2005 he had lost that
number one rating out of 19 years span
for three months
19 years for three months i mean that's
that's ridiculous again i mean your kids
were born and you have if you're a
champion maybe four or five years you
know a kid's boring and they live for
four or five years they don't even know
who you are you're not in memory okay
maybe eight or nine they see you and
they say okay he's the champ and then if
you lose the title then you're just
history they
people don't even remember michael
jordan some of the young kids okay they
hear about him but
it can turn very fast how long you you
sustain your excellence but kids were
born
10 years old teenagers and they're
almost
20 year olds when gary kept his shadow
over the world of chess he won 11 oscars
uh he won 15 tournaments in a row i mean
the guy was crazy
you're kidding the guy it was literally
who's going to be second place and that
you you can easily forget that you know
alejandro is sort of like the youngsters
who say yeah
when i when i was talking about michael
jordan to some kids and they say why are
you talking about michael jordan i mean
we we think of lebron james is number
one it's like
come on know your history
this guy gary kasparov just he kept us
all in a grip with his dominance like i
dominate that's what i do that was the
word he just simply dominated with his
energy even when we saw him come out of
retirement play against nigel short the
games he was playing we got a chance to
comment on alejandro it was just so
scintillate it's so powerful the
attacking style he burns with a
different kind of energy at his core so
that is something again magnus will want
to emulate uh will want to put his
numbers up to get the kind of resume
that kasparov had this incredible
dominance yes he has surpassed gary's
rating of 2851 yes he had so many
had so many great uh results in his time
but
gary was just a world champion for for
for the ages i i have without question i
have a lot of stories of gary because of
course i played him numerous
times around the world but one of uh a
favorite story is kind of funny
there uh bezelcock had organized a
match between the highest rated player
judith polgar one of the highest rated
male players at the time alexi shearoff
okay
and gary had come as a special guest in
prague
to visit the event
i was doing commentary
and it was one of those sharp
nadors with bishop e3 knight g4 bishop
g5h6 where are you going away
you're moving away bishop h4
and the players were like 18 moves into
the game and um
the situation was really really sharp
and the players had used like an hour
and a half each
and gary came into the
analysis room and he says yes sir do you
understand i don't understand i go what
is it that you don't understand
he says the game hasn't even started yet
and i said i beg your pardon he says
well i've already analyzed this position
long ago
you have to go here here here here
and it was sort of like what
you know the players had spent hours
getting into a position that gary had
already looked at
very very deeply and new inside and out
so his knowledge about the openings was
light years ahead of his colleagues now
one of the things i actually like about
the rivalry between the different
players that are at least attempting to
create a legacy the way that magnus
carlsen wants to do it is that he's such
a different player i think that's right
you cannot imagine a more different
world champion that's right
than magnus carlsen i mean as anatoly
karpov too as vladimir kramnik right and
you would think that you know after the
computer generation and everybody coming
up with computers that the guy after
gary kasparov is going to be the best
prepared chess player that has ever
stepped on this earth and magnus carl's
not even the best prepared chess player
on that stage
good point his openings are
not his strong point and it's something
that he freely admits basically
everybody says so and it shows time and
time again but he is
such a magician when it comes to certain
positions that we come to expect that oh
my god it's equal
that means magnus has an edge right and
it's something that really
quantifies him and it's something that i
really like about his style is that it's
so completely different from his
predecessor whereas gary i mean i think
was such a machine not only tactically
and aggressively
but he was such a workaholic i mean in
the opening phase specifically not to
say that magnus carlsen doesn't work
hard but it just seems like he focuses
his energies on some other kind of
approach yeah well it's like a runner
the moment he hits a starter pistol
boy he's off and he's got a lead on the
opposition and gary
very very strongly believed in getting
an opening edge and then just you know
mashing you off the board
um but the contrast that's a good one
and i think for me it's the indomitable
the indomitable indomitable will that
gary this is the face you've seen before
yeah
truly
and uh magnus has it magnus has an
extraordinary
it sometimes you almost feel like he's
imposing himself on his opponents and
you can't understand why we're
we we're we're playing the same rules
aren't we guys you know
yeah it definitely makes it look like
it's different kinds of chess yes yes
absolutely we finally have a move from
maxine he played the move b5 which i
probably doesn't really change anything
but at least it doesn't go into a direct
draw so so b7 b5 yeah also he gives
himself an option that when he gives a
check
he's also got an opportunity
to force the trade rooks i'm assuming
that
yeah yeah that there's no checkmating
threats you know again uh
just the slight
slight vulnerability of uh black's king
getting checked along the h file
if you really mess up and allow
this yeah not gonna happen of course so
it would it definitely will not happen
but other than that there's nothing in
the resolution for white position for
either side yeah i mean it's almost
impossible to advance both pawns for
black especially because white always
has the opportunity
sorry of of putting the black knight in
a passive position
and well as i said that he plays the
move king f4 forcing the knight back
i was going to say we could take a break
in a short while just to recharge
ourselves and to see
seems like a good point to take a break
yeah and we'll be right back to see if
maxine and hikaru try to find new ways
of creating something in the position
sorry i just had to go
mr matheny what's your favorite part
about this sport
i think the strategy how much do you
hate to lose
i don't like it at all what about being
second guessed
i don't like that either well if i were
you i wouldn't move that rook
checkmate
sorry whether you've played chess for
years or never before come experience
all the sport has to offer at the world
renowned chess club and scholastic
center of st louis
you could fly to venice
or paris
or even copenhagen
you could fly all over the world
but why
when you could just come
to st louis
your trip begins at explorestlouis.com
welcome back everybody we are finishing
up the second round of the london chess
classic so far we have four draws and
the last remaining game is this one
between hikaru nakamura and maxine
bashir
and it looks pretty dead to us we did
have a few moves
being played as we were on break i don't
really think it changed anything at all
except now we actually have the
possibility of a repetition which is
maybe not such a bad thing it would be
welcome right well one of the things
that jennifer and i like to do when
jen's uh
in your seat alejandro is show all the
potential checkmating patterns because
it's you can never get tired of showing
checkmating patterns and there is one it
would be extraordinarily amazing
if uh
you you cooperated so to speak you would
walk into a check mate as white and i
was thinking that you were about to say
that you could have uh a draw by
repetition
something like this right yes
okay but when we did leave it let's just
catch up to what actually happened we
left it around these parts it takes d4
b5 king f4 knight drop back to h6 and
just to explain that move for a second
um
your
black defends the pawn on f7 the only
way he's going to lose the game
is um by this pawn on h3 you want to get
rid of that pawn and you want to keep
your king safe
and what's going on maurice is like ah
so excited rookie six
i've never been so excited by drop and
repetition here it comes
let's just repeat the moves come on guys
there we go
this one is definitely uh been drawn for
a long time and they're now looking up
and it's clear that there's nothing to
play for here sometimes you want some
great fighting spirit but this one
this is just a draw and
yeah
it's over yeah yeah
i mean and the players have uh
it looks like they've invited the
arbiter over to explain uh that it's
about to be
uh
repeated we do have a final result okay
so maxine bacilla graph with the black
pieces probably having an initiative
earlier in the game definitely chances
to take the full point was unable to
really convert and let's hikar escape
with the draw indeed
and today looked like this unfortunately
we had not the most eventful day five
draws and not exactly in the best way we
had a couple of games which didn't
really produce any kind of excitement or
any theoretical importance and it feels
like
black just held comfortably in most
games and the only one which was not as
comfortable was actually for white
exactly
as everybody drew their game no real
changes on the standings either as an
ishkiri continues to be the leader with
four and a half points and on last place
is wrestling topalov with only half a
point everybody else is on one
strange that our tour leader
is the
player in this uh event in the basement
especially after starting with two
whites you expect usually the player
that starts with two whites or the one
that draws number one to usually start
with the lead the lead yes but it's not
going to be the case this time topalov
finds himself at the bottom of the
standings as we see
the players just
quickly analyzing
their games a little postmortem usually
it's courtesy that you talk to your
opponent a little bit after the games
and just to share some of your insights
what you were worried about what you
thought you missed what you know well
the adrenaline is still pumping it's
sort of like dude did i miss a win right
what was my opportunity and
i thought you had this and normally the
players see uh
everything
uh that the other scene until
you know the guy said you did miss a win
right then you feel awful like where was
it what did i miss and then they
explained it to us like no
and we can take a look at tomorrow's
pairings as with white alexander
christchurch will be playing the
tournament leader annie shakiri maxine
vashayla graf who missed a really good
opportunity today will be playing
against veselyn topalov
karana will be playing in the american
matchup against ikaio nakamura a very
interesting
showdown
definitely vishy anand will be again
another classical matchup against magnus
carlson and mickey adams will be white
they're perhaps trying to push a little
bit as the wild card i guess the super
ultra solid live on aronian
yeah that a non-carlson match a
game you can't help but feel
that you know those two matches that
those guys have played with each other
still
unresolved uh blood between them and
from london we have jennifer shahadi
with mvl
hey guys i'm with maxine bashir lagrave
today some very enterprising opening and
middle gameplay how do you feel about
your opening
well i mean
i checked this
after i lost to anish in the same line i
mean i decided that it was still worth
you know checking this
in a bit of dubs because okay it's a bit
only with the tempo basically so it
should be good and i couldn't remember
the details but in general i think i
ended
it quite well so you take black
yeah i mean i was definitely
better at some point
i saw some nice ideas i
also played a
couple of moves too fast but
okay maybe it was not so easy anyway and
in the end game i should definitely have
put more pressure and
not
find myself under the pressure of the
move 40. will you we ever see you
playing a regular banoni
well i'm not sure about that but i
actually played a couple of those but
generally in rapid games
oh and how did you evaluate your
position after the sacrifice
after the exchange sacrifice i thought
i'm much better i mean but i couldn't
see a forced twin because this is what i
was actually looking for in this
position
but in general i have plenty of
compensation of course
so after today's game tired what's
what's your routine
well i mean it's a tough game but of
course we have to expect
such such games to happen in a
tournament if you especially if you want
to have chances to win i mean you have
to take some ways to
to
find
some unbalanced positions and well we
can stick our way quite often enough
very nice fights so i've been asking the
grandmasters some advice tips for the
young players since it's a weekend we've
got all these kids coming in and i know
you're very well known for your
calculating skills any book or video or
training that you did as a kid that
helped you with that
well as a kid i was
really doing a lot of tactical stuff but
yeah i mean i also
i actually i mean it was not the only
area i was working on because simply i
mean
i was good at it so i had to focus on
some other stuff but maybe what helped
me the most is maybe solving really some
difficult studies because it's all about
calculation but finding some really
clever ideas and you can
you know
it helps you develop
some creativity also
in your tactical skills got it in-game
studies all right so that's something
for you guys to do
um until tomorrow's round at the grand
chess tour london chess classic um mvl
we will see you tomorrow thanks back to
you guys in the studio
thank you jennifer well definitely end
game study something i always tell my
students that they should do right more
often some of them seem to hate it they
think it's too hard
true then but then you see something as
some kasparians
studying they're beautiful it's a kind
of a poetry and it motivates you to
study some more but yeah it really if
you can connect with some endgame
studies just as mbl was saying it's so
useful in your
practice your own games and another
excellent calculator is ikaru nakamura
who's with jennifer shahadi in london
and here i am with us number one
nakamura of course a favorite with st
louis fans um but today we were a little
worried
at what point were you most worried uh
well just wasn't a very good opening uh
i mean when i played this after f4 i
probably should have done something more
double-edged perhaps maybe i should've
gone for g4 or something but with the
way i played i was just uh worse and um
pretty much uh i basically tried to
trick maximum by going e5 and managed to
work but uh
wasn't wasn't pretty at any rate
and uh what about you what are your
advice i know you grew up playing lots
of bullet and blitz chess and uh still
often do
do you advise that for the young kids
here at the london chess classic um i
mean it's a good tool for
recognizing patterns um
i think in general whether it's blitz or
it's just normal shots i think really
it's very important just play as much
you can so you have a better pattern
recognition but that being said there
are many different approaches and uh
what worked for me certainly would not
work for other people so i think it just
depends on the person much more than uh
than you know
any sort of concrete you know
straightforward advice it depends on the
person how they how they study and learn
learn best so it's very much up to the
individual is there any reading
threshold where you feel like bullet is
useful like a 1400 player playing bullet
might be too fast do you have any
opinions like that i mean i think bullet
and blitz both uh i think up to maybe 22
2300 it's very beneficial and after that
it's uh
it's not beneficial at any rate but um
i think just in general there's there's
no drawback at the lower level so i i
don't see any reason to advise slightly
weaker players to not to not you know
play blitz and bullets i think it can
only help it can't hurt all right great
there you have it play one minute until
tomorrow right tomorrow's game
with nakamura here and wrapping up round
two of the london chess classic
back to you guys let's take a quick look
at the standings after today's rounds
exactly let's see exactly how we are
looking up as
we have
this is just one decisive one decisive
game in the entire tournament we have
the ten games the ten games as we have
anish giri leading the pack with one and
a half it seems like everybody else has
one point except for wrestling tapa who
was the victim of yesterday's round with
only half a point that he drew alexander
gristrok today
if i may i have one piece of advice for
young uh scholastics players
don't agree to early draws just play the
game to a finish
that's my best advice maurice any
comments
hey uh we appreciate to the choir yes
absolutely well today's games were not
early draws necessarily but they
certainly weren't going to be bottles of
excitement moving forward we could have
almost called this one from our bedrooms
they did not really put up any
contentious games although a couple of
them really tried certainly this last
game we just saw the good news
is that after
that much rest they still got a lot of
energy so next tomorrow's games should
be more fighting chess there's some
interesting matchups to play certainly
and we'll see whether or not the gloves
come off and the players decide you know
i need to start taking a lead here at
some point so looking forward to
tomorrow's games uh so far here at the
london chess classic
well thanks for joining us today
remember that tomorrow is also an early
round as we'll be broadcasting live from
st louis at 8 a.m hour time 2 pm london
time and join us for round 3 tomorrow
wonderful alejandro great broadcast yes
sir thank you for joining us
you